Yeah.
Rogan experience day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Brian, I want you to apologize. All
the nice people out there in the world.
I'm sorry I ever logged into the wrong
use dream account and I guess the sound
was too awesome. So the
sound was too hot. Yeah.
If I had to restart the computer and every
time I restart the computer it always
goes back to all the
defaults for some reason.
So like the sound is really hot and uh,
my,
my like login is saved in
this, you stream. Thanks.
So automatically I just pay it,
you know, it screws everything up.
So every time I've restarted I have to
make sure everything is smoking weed
before it totally. We
have to, you know, we do,
we need a little yellow checky
checklist thing for you. Yeah.
Can Channel you're on
the weed gets too much blame, you
know what I mean? He gets it, right?
No, it does. It does.
No, I mean like when I'm,
when I'm doing stuff like you get
stoned and you get, and everyone's like,
all right, let's start now. Let's start
now. And you're like, okay, you know,
and plan. I'm just fuck, when
do you Dan? I'm just trying to,
I'm just trying to a backup lead.
You know what I mean?
He gets a bad rap speaking and we,
we got a,
Tommy Chong is going to come
on the podcast on Monday.
It's fucking awesome. Yeah.
That should be very fun. He a
apparently is using that. Uh,
Rick, you know that Rick Simpson thing,
have you heard that the cannabis oil,
there's some like some oil that
you can make with cannabis. Yup.
It's supposed to be super, super healthy
for people who have a good friend.
A good friend of mine came to La.
He's, uh, he's from the east coast.
He's got brain tumors in his head and
he's supposed to die in six months.
This was about a year ago and hardcore
10th planet is one of my top soldiers for
sure. He a man. It's,
it's weird because in the,
in the position that we're in,
we get a lot of people with,
you know,
there's a lot of people out there that
have cancer that her fans as well.
You know what I mean? And when
we're dealing with, you know,
this is not an uncommon thing to have a
student or someone come to me and have
cancer,
this happens all the time.
People are like dying and it's crazy the
spot that we're at. And we're like, fuck,
well there's a gigantic amount of
people in this country. You know,
you're gonna run into some people that
are sick and it's, it's, it's, um,
it's very humbling. Well,
this guy, he, you know,
he started that cannabis oil
therapy and his last checkup,
the tumors stop.
Not only did they stop growing,
did they shrank like 40% and his doctors
are like amazed at what's going on and
he's on this
cannabis oil therapy.
It's becoming really popular
now. You know, there's reports,
I don't even think it makes you
high, right? No, it doesn't. No,
it doesn't make any money at all.
So it's, it's not even an issue
of whether or not it's people are taking
this and getting, getting high on it.
The only way pockets your
highs if you heat it up.
I guess that's what's been explained
to me. Like you can't just eat it,
but when you eat it, if you just eat
like the leaves, it's really healthy.
They say like marijuana,
like the flowers and the leaves
are incredibly healthy for you.
Like really it's great thing to juice.
Like people should juice actual
marijuana more popular announced yet.
So I have a friend who who's at this,
I dunno,
his tumors are shrinking,
which is crazy and doctors are baffled,
but he's been on that, that cannabis
therapy and it's working and it's,
and it's becoming more and more popular
and all these studies are coming up.
Well,
real legit scientific studies that have
shown that marijuana shrinks tumors.
It seems like every week or every other
week there's this new study that comes
out that proves that somehow marijuana
can cure some kind of cancer.
Here are some kind of
cancer there and it's,
it's becoming so popular that I
don't even retweet all of them.
There's just too many damn studies.
True. Am I going to ask my shit?
There's just too many fucking studies,
so I'm only re tweeting the juiciest he's,
it's crazy.
There's all this evidence,
all this proof that marijuana
is just wonder plan.
It's not just an ordinary plan.
It's not just a plant.
It's like an Italian magical plant.
There's all this proof
and people still deny it.
It's still a schedule one drug and crazy
as that coke and heroin are scheduled
to cause they have medicinal use
supposedly. Yeah. That's crazy.
Yeah,
it's completely ridiculous.
How about that video of that
one congressman grilling
that chick from the d and
check his mom. Really?
She deflected everything
beautifully. Oh my God. You know,
all illegal drugs are dangerous.
They're a bi woman.
All illegal drugs are bad.
You know the DA's watching like in a
dark room, laughing their asses off gone.
That was brilliant.
You know,
she got like a fucking $500,000
bonus and shit for that. Really?
I thought she was terrible.
She looked brilliant. Well,
nothing's going to happen from it.
They just needed someone to go out there
and Jibber Jabber and just get past it
and whatever and then they don't
give a fuck. They got an old lady,
they got an old lady. So it's easy
for a guy. If you don't think that,
think too deeply about it.
You're like,
here's how could I be against an old
lady who's trying to keep us off drugs?
You know what I mean?
An old lady trying to keep us off drugs.
So a lot of people with the
shooting. How old was she? She,
she looks like 36 or 40 she's like
60 [inaudible]. Yeah, she was all,
they got an old lady up there and see
all I got out of that, that was that.
She was joyless.
I didn't get her age.
I got just as joyless woman perf
out there working. Brilliant.
Just the best old lady come
out and just say whatever.
They're like laughing in the back room
cause you don't really, they don't really,
they're not really accountable and
nothing really is going to do that. Yeah.
Do you think like they don't
know all the truth and shit.
They know what they're trying
to suppress it.
So how do you suppress it?
Fuck where they want to grill someone
in the DA. I'm not going. You Go. No,
I'm not going in any fucking
make the secretary go out there.
I'm sort of million dollars.
Just say, just say drugs are bad.
Just see trucks are bad and it worked
because it's on video and it's not going
to change shit. And it was like,
you know, she tried to um, you know,
different addictive properties.
All drugs are bad,
drugs are illegal. Is Marijuana
more addictive than heroin? Um,
I don't, uh, they're both illegal and
both of what is more, more addictive,
marijuana or heroin,
which in your opinion is more addictive
but both have addictive properties.
Both are illegal and you
choose a or B. Yes, exactly.
But it's like jeopardy on Saturday
and you are an expert on this.
You should know this.
Is Marijuana more dangerous then
pills and prescription pills.
All drugs are illegal. All
drug. She was brilliant.
It was perfect.
It's so weird.
It's so represents like if it was a
movie and this was like the frustrating
point in the movie where people were
starting to get all the information and
started to realize that
this, the structure that
they've got set up, it just,
you don't have to live this way.
We just lived this way because it's
been set up for us before we had any
information on how things are really
going on behind the scenes and then you,
you see something like this,
I mean this is,
this is the thing that would make people
rise up if that was really the drug
enforcement agency that
was really their attitude.
That's really their take on it.
That's really a spokesperson for this.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah, watch that video.
It's congressman grills d a
agent or something. So hilarious.
It's talking about like
fucking prescription pills.
They're talking about abusive
prescription pills, but you know what?
They're not talking about stopping those
prescription pills were being made.
Someone's always going to get them,
so it's always going to have a backend
because someone's always going to happen.
You can't stop. You can't
stop prescription pills.
And make prescription pills.
You can't do both, you know, so you never
going to stop them. That's horse shit.
So when they say that they're,
they're,
they're looking to cut down on illegal
prescription drugs. Like what ever,
what, what, uh, what kind of a
fucking smoke screen is that?
How much money is that even? How much
money is it compared to the legal ones,
the people who are legally
selling the exact same shit,
but because the doctor says it's cool
to take oxycontin every day for the rest
of your fucking life. You're down
in there. Next thing you know, Whoa,
you're a junkie. That's
legal though. That's illegal.
But marijuana, you can't grow. You
can't eat this incredible plant.
Even if you were completely uninterested
in getting high, if you just said,
the nutrition of this
plant is unquestionable.
If you look at the amino acid profile,
if you look at all the nutrients in it,
look at the fibrin. It's an incredible
super food. It's better than Kale.
It's like, but it's so expensive. You
could never eat it because it's illegal.
But if it was legal,
it'd be cheaper than fucking Kale.
That would be a real problem.
I know a bunch
of people that lived in
northern California that
prosper off of the illegality
of it that were arguing,
they were going to vote against it.
If it came on the ballot. They're like,
we make more money. If it's illegal.
They were,
they were ready to go gangster.
They would rather go gangster and then
make it a little bit of extra money then
have it like that's like contrary to the
whole idea behind weed in the first put
money takes precedent. Yeah. It's amazing.
It's amazing how strong the pole is in,
in some circumstances over like what
would be good for humanity. You know,
man, fuck it. I go to the TV
are going to pay for, you know,
could you imagine that some assholes grow
and he's like organizing people to try
to stop the, the, uh, initiatives to make
it legal. Fuck. Keep it illegal, dude.
Keep it illegal. Just you and me and bro
worked together. I'll get you the weed.
You give me the cash. Selfish
bitches. So can imagine.
So how self hating would you have to be
to be a pothead who grows weed and you
vote against it being legal
fucking piece of shit.
You fucking dummy.
That's some silly bitches.
Don't say Spiderman. The,
I won't see Spiderman.
We talked about this earlier before we,
uh, were brought to the wrong channel.
Tobey Maguire is a way better. Spiderman's
funny. Yeah, the new one's not,
it seems cold.
You can't keep rebooting shit man.
So I think they should repeat it one
more time and then just get that last one
and just make it Toby back and make it
not explain to me what the coolest part
was. It's like they use slow motion
a lot, kind of like matrix stuff.
They used it a couple of times
and it was really beautiful.
So I think they should slow
down the movie, make it slow.
But Tobey Maguire doing jokes, dude, I
thought I told him McGuire was awesome.
Batman. I thought it was perfect.
Spiderman, Spiderman, Batman.
He, he like was a perfect Peter
Parker. Yeah. Perfect. Perfect.
It's exactly what I imagined when I
was reading a comic book where this guy
seems like, um, twilight,
Spiderman and I got emotions,
I get bruised and scratched
you bitch.
And then there was some really cool scenes
where they tried to do like, like a,
like if you were the person like you
know, like a spoiler in right now. Not,
not at all. I'm not giving away any plot.
This is like more effects and stuff,
but there's probably like
first person shooter style,
like where they just failed at it.
Like it's like,
you know how like in a video game where
that you will see the arms calm and got,
it was a three D it was three d imax
and it was just like these little hands
going like here in the corner or
something. I'm like, no, it's not,
you're not doing it right like it. So you
want it like a full arm slowed it down.
Like, like if you were first person
move while he's swinging, you know,
made it look super cool. I
think that would be way better
than then. I don't know.
It just Spiderman by the way is way
more bad ass and an actual spider.
If a spider,
it was the size of Spiderman,
he wouldn't be able to
fucking shoot webs that far.
And they hold themselves explaining
the technology this time I behind it.
I don't know if I like
that. And uh, also they uh,
they redid the whole uncle Ben things.
Do you the whole time you're like,
you don't have care cause you know
what's going to happen to him.
He saw how it was going to
happen in the previous thing.
It's like before it used to
be in a comic book, you know,
it wasn't translated in person. In
a movie, you get to see it again.
I had to see it kind of again and
they changed it a little. Yeah.
That is kind of wag right down in a movie.
Like Mary Jane wasn't around and it
kind of freaked me out, but she would,
oh Mary Jane at all. No, Mary
Jane bugged the hell out of me,
sons of bitches and I don't
know, man. It was, it was fun,
but it kind of bummed me out.
It just didn't feel like Spiderman at all.
There was no humor in the whole thing
and Spiderman is a comic book was was
humorous and your Bravo,
bravo hates like superhero movies.
The only superhero I like is flash.
There's a kick ass.
There was never a big flash movie was
there. I'll go see that. That's it.
Other than that, did you see kick ass?
I like that. Yeah. That's kind of cool.
You just don't like like stupid shit
like Captain America flying around and
shield and stuff.
I know most people like that shit
obviously cause they fucking come out with
three of them every year.
I know most people like that shit.
I'm in that small minority that I
wish I fucking like. I wish there was,
I wish every time a fucking new
Batman came out I got [inaudible]
do fucking anything. That's
crazy. That'd be bad man.
It looks fucking shit myself crazy.
I was not a DC guy when I was
growing up was a marvel guy.
There's something about that.
I feel like I'm still prejudice against
Batman or something because I don't
really care about it as much as
like the Avengers is fucking pumped,
man salmon and that that movie delivered.
Did you like the Avengers?
How dare you Eddie Bravo.
How everybody liked it do just
for the hulk alone. It's awesome.
The Hawk is amazing. Greatest Song
of all time. They'd nailed it.
It's like days used to do the
whole kit. It was like, you know,
first he did Lou Ferrigno. He did
a great job for a person. I mean,
if you're going to get a person to play
the hook, that's the perfect got right.
Giant fucking knew, but he was never
anything like the hulk in the comic books.
The hulk in the comic books was not a man.
It was just fucking freak.
This crazy big freak thing that it's
so fun to watch when he gets mad.
When the hulk gets mad,
you think about God damn,
could you manage if you could do with
that guy he do. He can fight anything.
The hulk is unafraid of
anything. He smashes everything
in front of. He smashes.
He smashes gods.
He grabbed a god and smashed him.
Just smashed them all over the grounds.
The fucking rubbles breaking up.
You have to like smashing Eddie. When you
watch it, it's still give it a chance.
I'll give a, the hulk alone is
so fun. I'll give it a chance.
He fucking goes after a jet,
like a Jenny shooting missiles,
Adam and he gets fucking mad. Goes
after the jet. I mean it's to be,
the hulk would have to be like if
you had to, if there was like one
thing you could do,
if you could like,
if they could give you like some
sort of a neural implant, you know,
what does the movie total recall type
experience where they simulate a reality
for you and you get a chance to try it.
Like what would you like to do?
I would like it'd be the hulk.
Can it be the hulk in an artificial
reality for just one hour?
You know how fucking bad ass
that would be. You can fly,
you can jump and fly through the air.
Bullets bounce right off you like nothing.
You could smash. I would want to be
seeing a pissed off mood all the time,
but you would only be fighting
bad guys miraculously. The Hug.
Never heard any good guys.
Direct answers. Spiderwoman now
you have the same power as Spiderman,
but she's a woman.
She's got boobs and a vagina.
So for one hour you get to be Spiderwoman.
Plus you can play with your boot
boots and vagina for an hour.
That's the best way.
And it's going to be a woman you'd
rather smashed in and do that. Fuck yeah.
Fuck yeah, because a lot of spiders,
when you fuck the, the female,
the female kills the mail.
That shit happens all the
time and we kill some dudes.
Fingers open, swing around New York, some
bs apparently when the orgasm die too.
Did you know that really? Some
fucking beast. Certain beans,
like when they orgasming or
take explodes and they die,
the nature has a way of making
sure there's not an overflow.
Making sure that,
you know,
we've got to even out this population
thing and the female spider does not trust
that male motherfucker. So after he
impregnates her, she's like, yeah,
I'm done with you. And she did Jackson,
which is really kind of fucked up,
but probably a good idea.
I mean,
if she loves her babies and
she's going to have babies,
you're going to trust all 1000
of her babies with this canteen,
male spider around. He might just eat the
babies if he's fucking hungry, you know?
She's like, I can't take that chance. I
just got to jack him socially Jackson,
I guess I was wrong about Spiderman.
I guess the amazing Spiderman
was a different storyline
then I guess one of the
other spider. So the comment at the
amazing Spiderman, the only main one,
like the w rights where like Peter
Parker and the amazing Spiderman or, oh,
I don't know.
I mean nerdy to me the fuck
out like a web of Spiderman.
I don't even know. So now I'm really
confused. So sorry, nerds. I fucked up.
I fucked up. I remember Mary
Jane Doe Being Fault though.
They can't be changing plots like this.
Amazing Spiderman was Mary Jane.
I think up a new superhero bitch.
All right. You have to keep changing.
Don't change Spiderman. Right? Fuck.
He probably doesn't give a shit.
He would get mad. We would
go to movies like, well,
I know this guy's going to live.
He always would get upset.
You can never just enjoy it. It was like,
this is so stupid. They're mad ass, man.
I,
there's some,
there's something about movies that I
could figure out if I could figure it out.
I hate it if it has me on my toes and
it's totally unpredictable and as a really
good storyline obviously. But that's what
I'm into. I like, I like not knowing,
that's what gets me excited, knowing
what's going to happen. You know,
all that money that I'll, that CGI
it takes for you up for Batman to be,
he's like in seven fights per
movie, seven big episodes where
he almost dies, right? He's a,
he's fighting all the shit, all that work
that's so expensive. And so, granted,
it looks so beautiful
and for me, um, minority,
that doesn't mean anything for me.
It doesn't do shit and grow up block plane
watching cartoons much studio or like
any of that stuff. I wasn't in the
comments because I watch cartoons.
I watched the Super Heroes, I guess
the super friends and I was like eight,
you know.
But did you like star wars growing up?
And I did like star wars growing up. Did
you enjoy Avatar? I like to have a time.
Okay. But that was a super
predictable movie, man. That
was a complete comic book.
Movie Avatar was the ultimate,
um,
like pre determined, like
predetermined, ending moving. No,
a superhero movie is the most that's
like, you know, Spiderman is gonna live,
you know, it's going to be the
Avatar dude was going to live.
He lived through the whole thing.
He became a fucking one of the
member of the noble people himself.
Avatar wasn't as predictable as
Spiderman come on. No Way. Oh Dude.
It's by no means the most predictable
movie. Batman or Superman,
all that shits the same thing. But this
movie is predictable too because the guy,
I mean w w not even predictable
because I don't think that,
I shouldn't even say predictable.
What I should say is it follows
like a pretty obvious pattern.
It follows a pattern with a purpose
person that you're focusing on in the
beginning is probably going to be alive
at the end. Like 99.999% of the time. Yes,
but it's not as clear as a superhero
movie that's called Spiderman. You know,
Avatar wasn't a person of
Avatar was like a chick.
You knew that or up dude
or something like Avatar,
the fighter and he's going to follow it.
I see what you're saying.
It's because it's a science fiction movie.
You don't consider it a comic.
It's Vince. I worship Tara. I'm not
trying to watch it back on. It's good.
I know what you're saying. It is. It's,
it's less ridiculous than a Batman.
There's different levels.
When I say it's a comic book movie,
I say that with a compliment
because I loved that movie.
I thought most people do know. Most
people love that shit. You know? I just,
I just can't feel it. But you felt
avatar and I'm saying that Avatar,
he is very much like,
in a lot of ways it's like a comic book.
It's not like a superhero movie.
That's what I meant.
I meant like a superhero comic
hero. Like, like my name is Avatar.
I'm going to save this alien planet.
Did you watch that shit?
Did you enjoy like Clint Eastwood movies?
Like those half humor movies,
like every which way,
but loose now really told them
tool around. I don't
know. Do you remember him?
He eight.
I barely remember.
I did see Bj and the bear and Bj and
the bear. I mean, I was into that shit.
Isn't it weird now that we
know so much about chimpanzees,
like something that kid that's student
in Africa just got his fucking testicle
ripped off,
his fingers bitten off.
They dragged them for like two kilometers
or something like that. I mean,
he's really scary shit and they beat the
fuck out of this kid now that you know
so much about chimps is really a
hard to watch. Like Bj and the bear.
And this dude's like tooling around with
a chimp. It's not even really a chip.
It's a baby.
It's a little baby chimp.
It's like a little three year
old or something like that. Like,
cause that's about as old as you can
get before you got to circle out that Bj
and bringing in a new Bj or bringing a
new bear or whatever the fuck his name is.
You can't have that. He can't
grow up. Cause if he grows up,
he's going to fucking drive.
You know?
Imagine sitting in the cab of a truck
with a giant male chimpanzee and he's
like, how about I just fucking drive
right now? Just grabs that wheel from you.
What are you going to do?
It's going to bite your fucking nose
off. Brian, some due to work at a zoo,
brought home a baby chimp because her
mom has the baby, the chimps mother died.
And at that same time she had the person
that worked at the zoo have this dog
that just had puppies, had four
puppies, like this big massive.
And she brought that fucking chimp home.
And that massive took in that
champion as a child of its own. Oh,
I got all these pictures of it. It's
incredible. They're like all hanging out.
It's like a little baby chimp.
Holy Shit. You know what I'll do?
I'll tweet it to you. You'd be able to
see it there? Yeah, I could tweet it.
Would you rather be she hawk?
What's that like?
She Hawker halt for an hour. She hulk or
Hawk for an hour. Is there a she hulk?
Yeah, it does. That's a strong,
maybe not his check dude. Why do you keep
trying to turn yourself into a check?
Because I mean if you could have
a vagina for an hour, just don't.
You'd rather be the lingering stores.
The Gorney weaver.
Did you look the Harris so you really
get seriously, are you serious?
You really want at the time and one hour,
it could be for one hour to be Spiderman
or spider woman where she hawker,
she earned made a fire and so you could
feel what it feels like to get clocks
go, didn't know what it feels. A robot
from the towns. You're curious about that.
It doesn't have to be a fantasy
to just use your battles,
have boobs and hold one
hour besides no period.
No period. This is fresh, fresh as
big come for one hour, one hour dude,
you would get bored.
You would want to start using it.
You'll be out on the street going,
who wants a fuck?
I've got 40 minutes left as a woman.
Yeah. But if you're super woman,
imagine flying around like on top of
like the earth and just go and look how
beautiful it is and then start fingering
your pussy and sucking on your own
tissue. Maybe it was weird. Why did you're
doing, maybe it will stain your, your
brain and then when you come
back to being a man again,
it's imprinted in your memory
now you'd just become gay. Maybe.
Was there a story about a dude who got
in some sort of an accident and then
became gay? It was like, uh, yeah.
I think like rugby player cause he's
looked at the pictures of him before.
He was like sucking dicks and stuff like
that. I mean he just had like really?
He looked gay. So you think it was just a
good excuse? Yeah, like you realize, hey,
life is short. Maybe. Why don't I
just say that I just got knocked gay.
I don't know.
Oh yeah.
I just think if you're going to do it
for an hour and you can get to fly around
and look at nature. When I
told finger yourself, okay,
well I could see your logic.
You've really wouldn't do it for
an hour. No, I'm not really into
being a chick at all for an hour.
What if it starts to try?
You will never be convinced that you
can fuck what you're saying right now.
Shit, that's deep shit.
What you're saying,
this is millions of people or one hour.
You have to deny that Shit Brian,
to do this is like a mood from the
eighth to buy it. Deny it. Say that.
You're just trying to be funny
right now. No, I think say the hour.
It would be kind of fun. You're curious
to see how it would be to get rail.
You could make that happen.
You don't have to it,
you could actually make that happen.
I'm just saying man, like most drugs,
I'll try it once.
Wow.
But not facts or anything like
that except for a woman. No,
no, no, no. I'm saying if I could
be spider woman or spider man,
might as well be spider one me. Cause you
have boobs and a vagina. I'm not saying,
I'm not saying it like, Hey, I want to
have a sex change. I know to thinking,
well why not?
If you're going to go all out,
if I was 12 and I lived in the eighties
I probably would agree with you. Right?
I'm going to say no. I
feel creepy. Listen man,
it's still saying,
even contemplated the thought.
I mean it's a funny thing for men,
but even contemplated the thought of
what it would be like to have, you know,
to switch places and to be a woman,
you know,
just what would it be
like if you were born?
I will never thought it ever and
I've never wanted to be a woman to,
but if I had to choose between
spider woman and spider man,
I think I might go with this. You're
saying, I understand what you're saying,
but I'm saying it's a funny thing that
people get really uncomfortable about the
idea of even pretending
that you're a woman,
like or allowing yourself to even think
what would life be like as a woman like
matter? Like what are you doing? What
are you doing over there? You know,
like it's a, it's a legitimate thought.
I mean there's only two sexes. Okay.
One's male, one's female. If you
happen to be male and heterosexual,
how much do you understand about what
it's like to be a female heterosexual?
Do you really understand it? No. You'll
know you're standing your side of it.
What would you, uh, you know, there was
like a little thing, like a little chip,
like total recall style and you can be a
woman having sex and you can experience
what it feels like to be a
woman having sex with a man.
Would you do it or
would that make him gay?
I'd be super woman would flight
the Eiffel Tower and just going,
what would be some shit the girls
would find out and they'd be like,
really creeped out about you. You're
like, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a
minute, wait a minute.
You did at all the things you
could do with total recall.
You went and you were a woman
getting fucked by a guy.
Is that what you're telling
me? Well, I'm just, you know,
it's not a gay thing at all. I just
wanted to understand the experience.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You could have done anything and all
that money and you decided to be a girl
getting fucked by a guy. Well, you know,
I mean I don't think of it that way.
I think of it as like, you know,
experiencing something new. Otherwise
it'd be like completely out of my reach.
It like there's a joke coming. You know
what I mean? It does. It sounds like that.
It's like one a year,
early,
two thousands you're talking to some
chick on the phone. Wait a minute.
You mean to tell me girls
would not be happy with that?
I wouldn't be happy if I was a chick
and I found out a dude pretended to be a
girl and got fucked by cock and be like,
Whoa, how much that stays in your head,
how much that stays in your head,
how much is the pleasure of caulk that
you enjoyed so much as a woman for that,
you know, whatever amount of time. How
much of that is in your memories still?
Did you love the cock during that time?
Okay,
well cause then you still love the cock.
They could turn the gay fuck around.
I'm just saying, we're not saying
you're getting fucking happened.
I'm talking in comic book in the future.
That's probably what game's all about.
It's just some new evolutionary
exchange so that we can, uh,
have like less people.
What I think is gay or,
and this has been happening a lot on the
ice house, chronicles his other comics.
I think it's happened twice now saying
if they were in a steam room and a Brad
Pitt or George Clooney walked in,
would they totally fuck them?
And I think Burt Chrysler said yes.
Bert Kreischer said he would fuck
there was somebody else. I can't cry.
She was just being funny. No,
but they were all being serious.
I don't know if it was
Bert Kreischer at night.
Somebody tweet me if they can remind me.
You're saying you don't know if
it's him. That's a serious, it was,
I think it was rob Lowe was correct.
It's a serious allegation.
You better know that name is correct.
But that's been happening.
That's been happening a lot lately. And
I'm like, why would you want to do it?
He's like, dude, I think same AAA,
maybe awesome. But it was like, dude,
it's fucking Brad Pitt.
But yeah, but you know,
you know that this is all just for humor.
You can't pretend these are real
conversations. You're average.
That's what I said. You're just kidding.
And they're like, we're done. Stand up.
Comedians don't, they're going for the
joke. Yeah. Okay. So whether or not, Bro,
I don't know whether or not Bert would
actually look. Burt, my, that Tom Cruise,
fuck him. Just for the story. If he,
Tom Cruise had a moderate
to small size dick and uh,
and he wore a condom and
Burton didn't have to kiss him,
Burt might do it just for the story
because where does the greatest stories in
the history of the world and you don't,
you don't have those stories without
taking some chances. I don't know.
But he might be willing to do it just
for the store. Most likely I'd say no,
just fuck. Is that going to get an and
Harrison Burg crisis? The fucking man,
it's the funniest guy of all time.
He's right up there with Joey d
as far as like, like ridiculous,
natural humor. He just so, just
such a silly guy. He's so fun.
You know, it's such a great
guy to have around, you know,
so that the last podcast, it was
all fun. Cruising can fuck him.
Probably just getting the last part
of the house was all fucked up.
It's in two parts. You know, we had the
Josh Barnett one you're talking about.
Yeah, we had, it's like a power thing
where I got electrocuted and shit. Yeah.
We have the ice house unfortunately had
a little issue with their electrical
system that led to Brian
getting electrocuted in his
fucking face. Yeah. And so,
uh,
so that night I had took a,
after you left,
after that podcast I took
apart the whole entire studio.
Courtney came over and we like went
through and throw away all this stuff.
I went through every wire to make sure
it wasn't on my side and I put it back
together and we had another podcast,
the bone zone.
And right before the podcast started,
uh,
some somebody put in between the alley
of the studio and the other building,
I think it was somebody who said it was
like an m 100 or something like that,
which is like a quarter stick of dynamite.
And uh,
it's a firework but it went lit it, but
it's super illegal and lit it. This,
I dunno,
like super loud.
I was inside like plugging the outlet
in after hooking up all the thing.
And I put it in and I like stood up and
it happened and I thought it was that,
you know, cause I'm so I
just got electrocuted and so,
but I filled out all my face, my
face like when like, like lobby,
like the impact and someone
threw a bomb at you pretty much,
but they were doing it in
between cause like, uh,
cause there was a comedy show coming
and coming out and some, you know,
do just threw it on the ground or
something like that. But where did it go?
Did it go inside the room? No, no,
no, no. Outside the room. Right by.
Right outside the room in that alley.
So it was in a conf confined
place cause to alley.
There's that space. Yeah.
And it was, yeah, man.
Fireworks or a fucking ridiculous. In
California. It's so God damn dry. I know.
People are shooting shit
up in the air all day.
See what the fuck is going on
in Colorado, man, you know,
there's this huge wildfire.
They think part of it was started,
one of the rumors that some kids were
shooting at things right there were
fucking around with guns and they
hit a rock or something like that.
It causes a spark and that was it.
That's all she wrote. So I shit myself,
we all ran outside smoke everywhere.
People freaking out.
I thought the building was blowing up.
Like I thought that the electric thing,
you know, and all those like, like
something is not right. Uh, and you know,
freaked out. Anyways, we did the
podcast. All this shit happened, uh,
after the podcast,
I'm driving home a good to the stoplight
and I was about to go to the gas
station, but I was like,
no, I'm going to stay.
And it's black dude starts walking up
to me holding two car stereos and like
something else,
some other box,
like a camera camcorder box or something
like that. He got and he stops.
He starts screaming at me and I turn up,
my stereo was a little bit, and then I,
I tried to roll up my window,
but my window, it's fucked up.
Like it's like some setting where I hit
it and it will like roll up halfway and
then roll all the way down.
I'm like,
it's been a hit it again and it rolls
up like only a little bit and then it
rolls down. I'm like, fuck,
I'm just going to keep it down.
The Guy starts screaming and I'm just
kind of ignoring them and finally unlike
in the corner of my eye,
I'm like, all right,
this dude's still staring at me and
screaming at me, so I better look at them.
So look at him. He goes, give me a fucking
cigarette. And I'm like, oh, all right.
He goes and he goes and he goes through
it on the mother fucking crowd. I'm like,
what? He goes, I'll go, I'll
go to jail for you. I've got
gun bitch. And I'm like, oh,
okay. At through the cigarette on the
ground. And he picks it up and he'd
just like stares at me for like a minute
and people were honking their horns
around because everyone else is seeing
what's going on and he fucking starts
acting like he's going to walk to me.
Like walk towards my window.
I'm the dude look fucking psycho.
Like he looked crazy and then, uh,
I just like the light turned green over
like when I like took off turbos style
in my car, but it was fucked up.
That whole day was fucked up.
That haunted house day.
Yeah. That was a weird day.
Josh Barnett was on the way up here
from Orange County, got a blow out,
barely controlled his car. He said it
was trying to go into the dividing wall.
You gotta hold it together,
pull over to the side of the road.
He got to get told it changes tired.
Then he got to the podcast.
By the time he got there, Brian had
been electrocuted in the face. Yeah.
That's sucked. I did you hear
it? Did you listen to her?
I saw this almost like see like a little,
there's a white park. Yeah. I was like,
didn't really see that. They're really
see that you saw it cause it was like,
yeah, that's um, that's not good.
Electrical Shit is fucking freaky.
Scary as fuck. UHMM electrical
fires, that kind of stuff too.
We gotta be real careful when
you get in sparks like that.
Who knows what the fuck
that's going to hit. You know,
weird chicken happened
when you got the storm.
Just hit through Ohio and like most
of Columbus doesn't have power race,
a lot of the whole east coast. Yeah. Yeah.
My Dad said that he won't have power
till next Wednesday. Jesus Christ.
So he has a generator just to do his
refrigerator and his TV and fans.
That's scary shit man. It's
like you have a generator. No,
I need to get one on shit.
It's scary to find out how easy it
is for the power of wow. You know,
it's scary number. When they were, there
was some sort of scandal in the, in,
in California and they were doing these
brownouts whether it would just shut
people's power off for a little while.
I don't remember what the scandal was.
It was, I don't remember
what, but there had been,
they had been shown that there was some
collusion involved in shutting people's
power off. I don't know the exact story.
I'm totally butchering it. But uh,
I remember thinking that like that was a
scary thing man, when that was going on,
when they would just shut the power off
in certain spots, you know, that's not,
wait a minute, you guys can't keep
the fucking power on all the time.
What are we doing that's really fucking
scary. Yeah, it is scary. It gets scary.
Like how much power do we have? We use
it all up like what's going on here?
That wizard last night is the second
time where I've been like, all right,
this is getting really dangerous out here.
You can, you never know man. When you,
when you drive,
you never know.
It could zig when you should've zagged
and all of sudden there's a crazy dude in
front of you.
You know when Justin Martin Dale
fucking window fixed and Justin Martin,
Martin Dale got recently
robbed and stuff like that.
Like a lot of people have been talking
about it and a lot of bartenders in
Hollywood have been getting robbed
because they have money at the end of the
night and they're leaving.
So people are,
these two guys are like targeting these
guys and I guess from a friend of a
friend,
what they're saying is that it's a really,
there's a really bad problem right now
with people getting mugged and La and
Hollywood, but they're not saying
anything because they don't want it to,
you know about a lot
of attention drawn to it. Right. But
like it's really bad. A lot of people,
well a lot of people are getting fucked.
The economy's in the toilet man.
More of a reason to do Jujitsu I guess.
Gun You,
yeah. You know what? I'm going to kill.
You want to get in a gunfight? No,
just we knew we need to figure
out what the fuck the problem is.
Our society is just,
it's so funny how little we do like in
terms of or literary require in terms of
government and,
and as far as like engineering our
future as far as like, you know,
figuring out a way to cut crime back.
Looking at all the methods, superheroes,
looking at no,
talking about looking at different
methods to rehabilitate people.
It took a little bit of Ibogaine
or Iowasca or you know, any,
any fucking,
anything that you could do that could
help like rehabilitate kids once they get
into trouble, once you realize that
they're headed down a bad alley, you know,
then we do like nothing for that. It
was, you know, very little consideration.
It's not like something that's
on the Internet every day.
They're talking about all these kids
that are growing up and shitty homes and
what we need to do is figure out a way
to provide some sort of guidance for a
kid that doesn't get it from home.
Some sort of a way to take advantage
of all these young kids and give them
something that no, no.
Like isn't that what,
like it should not be a part
of what like the government is.
It doesn't that make sense?
I mean if you,
if the you needed them for anything
wouldn't need like they would,
let's say we need to look at the future
of our youth. This is a, this is the plan.
We need to figure out a way to stop all
the fucking people from dropping out of
school need to figure out a way to pay
for more schools and that kind of shit
when you wouldn't that be the, the answer
and some, some way. In a perfect world,
what's wrong with this world?
This world worlds could be perfect
if everybody got their shit together.
If the world was filled with cool
motherfuckers. It is a perfect world.
We are the world we,
ah, the trilogy in it's,
it's totally possible for anyone to get
their shit together up to a reasonable
point.
I feel like a serial killer.
You probably shouldn't be fucking
hanging around even if you're sorry.
But you know what I mean?
For most folks,
it's very possible for anybody and at
some point in the life to have some sort
of an experience that puts them on some
sort of a path to eventually getting
your shit together. I don't,
I don't count anybody out.
I think it's almost possible for
everybody except extreme idiots that are
probably just here to dig holes. I think
there's gotta be a few of those too,
but other than that, right? Yes.
I'm so fucking fake, Chris.
I agree with you. Yes.
I'm so glad Tom.
All down.
I'm all down for positivity
and prosperity, all that shit.
Yeah.
I just think we have to figure out a way
to make people nicer in the best way is
all the shit they're trying to
keep us from. The best way is weed.
You see this long beach raid, they fucking
stepped in this kids neck as a kid.
Did nothing wrong. Complied completely.
They said, get on your knees,
lift your hands up. I stepped on his
back and then stepped on his neck.
Big fucking cop. Big, big guy, man.
It was just a clumsy stylic. Yeah.
I don't give a shit like he doesn't give
a fuck about him. Like I own you bitch.
She stepped on him like a carpet.
But the problem is they didn't know that
they were being filmed and there was a
camera up there and the camera
apparently records at a remote location.
It doesn't even record there.
So you can't like get the video.
So the cops couldn't do anything.
They smashed the cameras,
but they couldn't do anything
to get rid of the video.
Do this fucking video of them smashing
the cat. Well, it's the, first of all,
cops have no business smashing security
cameras. You have no business doing that.
You're supposed to abide
by the fucking law.
Just because you're a cop does
mean because you enjoyed that,
that episode of shield. When a, that
fucking, what does that was the,
the shield was that dude's
name Michael Chiklis.
Michael Chiklis would rough
people up and kick them.
Step on their head that this is real life.
You fucking cunt.
You're being paid by these people.
These people pay taxes. Fuckhead yeah,
watch the video. It's on, I think
harbor each rage on Youtube.
I think that's what it
is. Look, they, you know,
20 years ago they would've beat the
fucking kid to death with a bat and said
that he came out and we won a knife.
You know, if it was a, it was a bad cop.
I think bad cops today are under much
more scrutiny than bad cops in the past.
You know,
if you look,
look at like Serpico and shit like that
and look at those outputs, you know,
movies and you know, hear about the
stories of corruption in that movie.
Cocaine cowboys where the
whole Miami Police Department,
half of the half of one year of the
graduating class of the police academy,
half of them were murdered and the
other half of them went to jail for
corruption. Like they were all
gangsters. They were breeding gangsters.
I don't think that's possible today.
I think there's cops there are way
better than they've ever been before,
but a lot of them are under
a lot of stress and they
develop a fucking us versus
them mentality and they do shit like that.
Or they just step on some kids and
neck and they just did. It could,
they could and that's a county thing,
man.
You can't just do
something because you can,
you can't just step on some kid's
neck who's not doing anything wrong.
It's Kaizen young kid to the kid looks
like he's like 2021 years old, right?
It doesn't look, it looks like a
really young kid going after that guy.
Someone going after the cop should man,
this kid didn't do anything wrong.
He did everything they asked of them and
you know, it was, it was creeping is uh,
you know, I don't want to bring race into
it, but he's a black kid and they're,
you know, they're stepping on his back
and stepping on his neck and it's,
you know,
I don't know what the race of the cop was.
He looked like he was a white cop. I
don't, I don't know what the fuck he was,
but either way, man, that's
fucking completely uncalled for.
If that kid had been out there throwing
rocks at cars in the street, fuck yes.
Step on his neck. If that kid had
been out there robbing old ladies or,
or beating people up or, you know what?
Yeah, fuck yeah. Step on his neck, man.
Kick him in the fucking
head once you have him down.
But he didn't do anything and honestly,
you should just comply with the law.
You had him down on the ground.
Just handcuff him. Yeah. But
I'm saying if none other dangerous person,
you have to,
you have to do something to
immobilize them. You know,
if you've got them lying down on the
ground, man, I would for sure soccer,
kick him in the head if it was legal or
if you got to like a really dangerous
guy. Like if you, if you have like
some Ted Bundy type dude and you know,
and you, you're in a situation with him,
you know, we're, you know, he's, uh,
he's resisting arrest.
You're not gonna,
you're not gonna kick him in the head
while he's on his way down sticking his,
but like,
wouldn't you want to kill him
punching as hard as I can to the shoulder
punching in the shoulder? What's legal?
But do you think it is the guy,
if the guy makes a move on you,
are you allowed to hit him? Like how
does it, how does that work for a cop?
Cause cops have to be careful about that,
right? Yeah, for sure. There's, there,
they're always on edge because for sure,
most people don't like to be arrested.
And then you never know when someone's
gonna fucking freak out and punch you in
the face and try to get
away with something.
So for sure they have to
be on edge all the time,
but when they take it out
on someone who does nothing,
I can't take your side anymore
because now you fucked up and he's,
I'm on your side. When you're
dealing with the cons of the world,
I'm on your side.
But when you do that to a kid,
because he works in a place where
they sell plants that make you happy,
well then you're a cut. That's just the
way it is. This poor cop became a cunt.
He became a cut by doing his job, probably
didn't even realize he was a cunt.
He realizes that he's a cut now.
Now that video got out and
people realize like what a,
what a fucking shitty thing
that is to do to a young kid.
It's becoming real good business to ray
dispensaries and just rob them. Yeah,
they take their money,
they take the money now it
becomes more profitable for them,
for more states to legalize
it. You know? As medicine,
they're just going to raid and
fucking pillage. Yeah. Well, I,
I, you know, I hope there's some way to
stop that. I really do. It's a disgrace.
And it's just one of those things where
people are doing something just because
they're allowed to do something.
If you look at the allocation
of resources and how,
how much crime exists in our
world, you would say, well,
let's concentrate on the things that are
really hurting people. You know, his,
his marijuana really hurting people.
No, it's not. Well, you know,
what's really hurting people, murders,
you know, what's really hurting people,
drunk drivers, you know,
it's really hurting people.
People that are trying to harm people.
Uh, people that do assault and rapes,
people that are there.
It should be that.
That's the stuff that we should be
protecting people from. Number one,
when we get that under wraps,
then once you start looking at
some other stuff like, you know,
personal use stuff like alcohol, tobacco,
marijuana, everything, all the above.
I think we shouldn't examine them
all equally. But that's that. What's,
what's unfair about our society is that
these people that are supposed to be in
control supposed to be our leaders,
our first sure under a financial umbrella
of one aspect of the community that
trying to keep these natural drugs
illegal. The pharmaceutical companies,
they would,
they would go lose an incredible amount
of money if you took all the illegal
shit like Ibogaine and marijuana,
if that,
all that stuff started getting researched
and all that stuff started getting
laws passed and and government,
you know,
foundations where they set up Ibogaine
research centers where people go in to
relieve themselves of addictions.
If that shit started to happen and man
pharmaceutical drug companies would lose
a fuck load of money.
I'm not saying they want people to be
addicted to like oxies and shit like that,
but people are in kicked in and
then that money's coming in. Man,
that might come in and,
and it's not a little money,
it's rivers and rivers of money.
The pharmaceutical industry is so big,
even if they have the best intentions,
the amount of money is so staggering.
It just gets out there and then it
finds a way to get out their salesmen.
Even it's not the fucking companies idea.
They just need to take the
weight off their shoulders,
leave it to the pharmaceutical
representatives and the pharmaceutical
representatives.
They take nurses out to dinner and doctors
out to dinner and they fund like golf
trips and shit and they're like,
come and support us stuff and then like,
like street hustlers, you know, and then
they connected to the people. Then boom,
people just get pop pills every
way you look. It's amazing.
It's amazing that we, we, we, we see it.
It's all written right down right
there and yet the government doesn't do
anything about it.
If they don't investigate that instead
they go after medical marijuana
dispensaries.
That's ridiculous.
If you look at the things that are doing
harm in this world that you would spend
any time whatsoever, it's just
like, why are you doing that?
You haven't done your homework yet.
You haven't finished your job.
We haven't done the right thing.
Why are you concentrating on
these extracurricular things?
Because they're written down and they're
easy. It's written down that it's legal.
It's even though the community
would completely disagree,
if you look at allocation of resources,
I guarantee you the community would
completely disagree that forget about all
the murderers. Let's, let's,
let's get a team of people together that
aren't doing any other real police work
that day and make them do
something that's a boring,
make them rob a bunch of fucking people
that are selling marijuana state.
Legally sad. It's sad. It's sad that
the cops have to resort to that.
It's sad. It's weird seeing
the undercover cop in the,
in the video because he didn't like they,
he was dressed up like all teenagers.
The whole thing is creepy.
Completely sad is fuck.
I feel sad for the cops that
have to do that. I really do.
I think most cops do not want to
do bullshit, stupid fucking pot.
Dispensary bus, especially this one.
This one's so small. If you look at it,
it looks like it's just a tiny operation,
but they just destroyed it and
stepped on people. It's fucking gross.
You know the, the cop, I blame the
leadership man. I blame the leadership.
I think you know,
most of these street cops,
they do what they have to do because
they get, they get told what to do.
All right. I think that we had
a look at what we're doing, man.
You can't keep arresting people for
no fucking reason just because they're
selling weed. It's stupid. It's just
stupid. Let them pay taxes. God Damn,
and there's money to be made here
or treat them at least like humans.
At least you know the,
the,
the whole idea of like going after them
and rating them and taking the money.
It's so gross. It's disgusting.
It's like, what do you,
what are you preventing you preventing
any crime other than the stupid fucking
written thing that says somewhere that
you're not supposed to enjoy certain
experiences because the government
has deemed them out of your reach.
The government that hasn't even had
these experiences. That's, that's this,
this disgusting. Goddammit
Eddie Bravo. Yeah, man.
It's disgusting, right? Yes. Checked out.
You know the people at the high levels,
they know the truth.
They know how beautiful
and magical the plan is.
You think that's what real artists,
they do?
The people that they actually experienced
it. You don't think the pharmacists, uh,
business doesn't know that you
think they don't have any idea?
Of course they know you're
going to stomp it out.
If you work for a pharmaceutical business,
you just get pharmaceuticals
like a motherfucker like
every day or at the office
just trading pills back and forth
to each other. Oh, you know what?
I will say this man.
I fucked up my back the other day
and Jujitsu and I took a Vicodin.
I took a Vicodin and two percosets
and my back was still fucked up.
That shit fucks with your boner. First
time ever I went limp during sex. Wow.
I can I get a perk it? Yeah.
It was on two, two percosets,
maybe three and Vicodin and that
night I tried to have sex. My deck.
It sounds like your body
is probably doesn't work
poisoned at first time I went,
he's limping a long time.
Anyhow. That's a lot of shit man.
You supposed to mix them like that.
My back's fucked right now.
It's still fucked up. What party?
Your back. Your lower back.
Lower back and froze on me,
man.
I slept on the floor last night
and trying to try to work it out.
Apparently if you sleep on the floor,
I don't know if that's a myth that if
you sleep on the floor it's supposed to
like it's good for your past. She'd get
in isolation and that'll help a little.
It doesn't seem like it would be.
It seems like your back would be
ruined and sleeping on the floor,
but you get a massage or
anything. No, I haven't.
I haven't had time to use a pillow.
Go and need one.
I can go to a deep tissue person. Someone
who's going to fuck your shit up time.
Yeah, that's good too. But you might
be like in pain for a time massage.
They I want to bend you up and shit.
Yesterday I'm on no pain pills today.
Yesterday I was on the pain pills.
I'm a no pain pills today,
but, and it still hurts,
but at least I don't have
to take vicodins. Wow, man.
I never take shit when I get injured.
I hurt my back pretty
bad like four months ago.
It was a real annoying thing for a while.
I'm glad that I can just deal with it
because if I had gotten on something,
if I had taken some sort of pain pills,
I'd be taking it for a few months and I
who I could have gotten addicted easily,
you know? I don't know. I don't know what
the physiological effects of that are,
but I was in some pretty good pain most
of the time for like a whole month and a
half and a 98% of the time I have sex,
I'm high and that is a fucking my butter.
No, it does. It better. It makes, it
doesn't make you more compassionate.
It makes you more like sensual Bra.
Makes the organism actually see.
I'm weird about it. I even, I like, I
like weed, but I think alcohol, I love
fucking one.
I'm on alcohol [inaudible] ambition thing,
but a lot of people don't like the really
alcohol, you know, people can get it,
you know, whiskey Dick, you
know, or something like that.
If you get really fucked up,
you can get whiskey deck,
but you'd have to drink a lot. Yeah, I
would not. I would have to be not alive.
Yeah, of course. You're limited.
You have a glass of wine I've gotten
with correct before. For sure.
Real fuck. Yeah, for sure. I think I've
ever been done that too. If you fuck,
you start the problem when you start
drinking his alcohol reduces inhibitions,
right?
It removes your inhibitions and it
removes your inhibitions more with every
drink. So you know, if you're, if you're
a little, you know, a little tipsy,
you got like a little bit of
inhibitions. Throw up on a check. No.
Right.
As I was about to eat her pussy
hot chick, I was 19. I was like,
we were drinking greyhounds.
I'll never forget it was the gray house.
We just pound Greyhound
is, uh, I think it's Gen.
Uh, it's a plan. It's a grey hound.
It's, it's light green, light yellow.
I'm not sure what the alcohol,
a bunch of blueberries,
it's grapefruit juice and
vodka or something like that.
I think it's great food,
juice and vodka. Anyways, it was a
greyhound. Whatever the fuck it is.
I'm not a bartender.
So mad.
I couldn't believe I was getting
this piece sash. Super Hot,
open up the legs and right.
All I remember is
I threw up, grabbed me, she grabbed me,
they dragged me down the hallway and I
just remember scenes of going through the
hallway,
throwing up down the hallway and they're
trying to get me to the toilet and I
finally get to the toilet. I have
a couple more, uh, JAKKS left.
Never fucked her. I never saw her
again. Never saw that when I was,
there's no way you can
come back from that.
You can fuck up the throw up into her.
When I was young and I
use a lube on her ass when
I was prime carrot in there.
What's, take the carrot
out. Fuck in the ass.
Enzymes are retarded.
I think you burn yourself.
It probably burned it down. It's
this whole, sir, what do you have?
Bio Burns on your Dick.
Whatever. Whatever.
Fucking nothing. Come
on. Who loves it man?
Nobody ain't throw it up on your Dick.
Tried to fuck your
blow up. You threw up in her and then
just said it's all slippery down there.
Let me just start good
like Goolarri and shit.
Maybe I fell asleep balls going
down on my girlfriend once.
At least once. I used to have my
paper route. That's quite common,
but I didn't fall asleep cause I was tired
cause I fucking threw papers all day.
I got tired.
I'd be like drunk and I partied all night.
You just get home and pull down your
pants. You just fall asleep or something.
She goes to the bathroom and you're
just waiting. Then you're done.
She comes back and you're snoring.
[inaudible] paper boys. Yeah, I was.
How creepy is that now looking back,
they don't have, it wasn't always.
That was a paper man. I had a
car. I only delivered with a car.
I was in the six or seventh grade and I
remember waking up at 5:00 AM my parents
weren't even awake and I would like go
outside and find these newspapers and
like have to put them in the
bags. You know what, man,
it's weird now because the fact
that you were out there, you know,
on supervised and we know how creepy
people are, how creepy adults are,
but it's good for a kid to get
some sort of responsibility,
something that they don't
want to necessarily do but
they do and learn how to
like just fucking some shit in your
life is going to need to just get done.
You got to need to do that. You
know? And there's, there's a,
there's a good benefit to teach
you the kid that early, you know?
And that's what's great about a paper
route, a paper route. I was like,
I remember kids that I knew that
had paper routes when I was young.
They would like more organized than
the other kids. They're like more like,
like Jimmy's got a fucking
landscape business, right?
He's 13 fucking landscape business.
Like this kid,
he started out with a
paper route and then he,
I mean when the key was like fucking
delivering newspapers on a bike every
morning before school.
Like that guy's a ambitious is fuck.
Like he would get up like an hour and a
half before everybody else had to get up
for school and he would
go down with his bike,
get as newspapers and then fucking
drive around on his bike and deliver
newspapers. That motherfucker had some
sticktuitiveness. You know what I mean?
I had a friend did the same thing. One
of my good friends growing up. Yeah.
You think you are and
you learn how to like,
you learn how to work hard when you're
a kid like that, but that's not good.
I think. Uh, I was never good at
waking up early. It's torture.
It's not why I sleep is awesome. God
Damn. I'm enjoying my life right now.
It's one of the things monkeys like to
do. Sit back and fucking chill. Oh Man.
Can I just relax a little longer?
Yeah.
Apparently when you get older you
don't want to sleep in anymore.
You just wake up.
Is that true?
I've been waking up earlier because you
always hear like old people waking up at
six or five people weird. Who knows?
Everybody's got their own clock.
My clock is,
I'm up like,
it's been my clock since I was a comedian
or you, uh, or time to get you right.
Noonish noon. It, she'd
go that deep. Yeah.
I like to go noonish up really,
really early. I'm up late,
but you're always up later than me. I
usually like five. Yeah. The my best.
My best shit gets done.
My best work gets done at night when
I know everybody else is asleep from,
for whatever reason. I want to
know my whole neighborhoods asleep.
I want to know there's nothing,
there's no sound.
It's just like Mike Tyson shit
right there. I don't know what,
I don't know what it is.
Didn't he get up like at three because
no one else was working out. Yeah.
We'll get up at three o'clock in the
morning because I knew my opponent's
wouldn't be doing that.
That's really good, man.
Mike Tyson is one of the,
he's an easy one.
Easy one. Yeah. Tyson and Arnold
and uh, those are like the staples.
Yeah. For a while, when we were younger,
it was captain Kirk and Jack Nicholson.
Remember everybody would do
a Jack Nicholson impression.
Yeah. It's a weird thing,
dude. You can miss the funniest
of oppression right now.
I don't know who's like the funniest
impressionist? Who's like the,
that your favorite guy. That's Michael
Winslow. A seamless, sandy does.
He's still around.
He's,
he's the guy that makes insane noises
with his mouth. He still does voice,
just like whammy pedals and shit.
Like his show is ridiculous.
Like you can't believe that it's actually
coming out of his mouth. He did. Um, um,
uh, what is not purple
haze? Fuck. What is the, uh,
I forget what the fucking Stan
Voodoo child he did Voodoo child.
The beginning with his mouth.
You should actually pull it up cause
it's kind of fucking incredible.
Michael Winslow. Michael.
Yeah. We played this like,
did we play at like 10 episodes
ago? Yeah. I don't remember playing.
I tell you to shut. The only way I know.
No, I didn't. You told me about it.
Did I really? Yeah, sure. Yeah, we played
in, I forgot, but I want to see it again.
Can we see it again please? Cause I, um,
I forgot how, I think it was
a long time ago, dude. Now,
cause I remember it was
about maybe 20 episodes,
but there's something cool about
watching someone imitate. Oh,
you know who was a fucking awesome
impressionist dice clay. Yeah.
Dice clay has like the best
John Travolta. Amazing. Ciao.
Ciao. Freddie Lockhart. Jeff Richards
is really good. It's really good. Yeah.
Freddie Lockhart's amazing. Freddie
Freddy Lockhart. It's Morgan Freeman.
That's probably one of the
best impressions I've ever
heard is as dead on as you
can get. Like if he called
you up, you know, and said,
I'd like to put you in a movie,
you'd be like, whoa. Shit.
Being a movie with Morgan Freeman.
This is crazy, man. This is going to
freak you out of the original artists.
Can you eat? Yeah. Alright.
Alright. Have you heard this?
This is a dude with a good heart
and then Michael Winslow, his mouth.
Oh, it's whole lot of
love. That's what it is.
Fuck yeah,
yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Okay
man.
That's his mouth.
No,
there's a lot of comedy snobs out there,
man that got no respect for Michael
Winslow. You know, I think that guy,
that's incredible. That's amazing
genius. It's people are like, oh,
he's making noises with his mouth. That
is completely not just what he's doing.
He's on some crazy, another level
with that. Yeah. That is wild,
man.
That was great.
The fucking noises that he can make with
his mouth and the way he did an intune
and even as same was good. Yeah. His
fucking Robert Plant was good. Yeah.
That's amazing.
You have to watch that folks who would
check that out on youtube because it's,
it's, it's a weird thing to watch
it watch it and go like, wow.
Like you really get the,
you see the guy that's his mouth
motherfucker. You think he
smokes weed? He's got two.
If he doesn't say yes, if he doesn't,
I would be shot. God, if he doesn't,
he's even more impressive.
Yeah. Imagine if he does it.
You got to get them high and then w shit,
he'll take that shit to the next level
to matches the fucking noises like I
would make. If he doesn't, then he
got some shit. Wonder if when he met,
when he fucks,
if he has like a little joke you guys
did a laser probably throws his voice.
Tends to be other people
who probably has that killers
cause everyone's got it. Okay.
Now I got a cool but he's probably got
a fucking one that's in stereo while he
probably can pretend to be different
dudes too. Yeah. Checks like damn,
come in with a fucking Australian cattle
ranchers had on long mustache and a new
voice.
I just want to eat this policy.
If there was a thing like what we were
talking about earlier about actually
having an artificial experience,
you know, and, and you know,
if we ever get to the point
technologically where they can do that,
like shut you off and tune you into
some crazy fake avatar world for like an
hour, would you be willing to take that
chance? Would you be willing to try that?
It depends. If I haven't
been China I would be um,
cannot just for one hour. But
I mean, would you trust it?
Would you trust it?
Do you mean would you,
would you look like when you
have a second dog experience,
the scariest part about it is right
before you're about to do it. You know,
when you're like, fuck, I
can't fucking let go here.
If people were dying from this
shit, no, I wouldn't do it.
I'd wait for the what it would,
if it was the first time,
you wouldn't want to be like the,
the first half of the artificial lip.
Yeah.
I would trust that more than trusting
like cricket mobiles thing to the Moon
because then all the fucking
commercials if you have you been, uh,
another person or another life,
if you have chosen spider woman,
you could have cancer will fight
for you. You know what I mean?
You never know these pills
that come out a year later,
they're giving you fucking heart attacks.
Well,
there's some of them that are certainly
doing that. Doctor [inaudible],
doctor Drusen deep shit.
What's up with that?
Doctor drew apparently was paid to
talk up or allegedly, I should say,
paid to talk up the sexual
side effects of certain,
um, uh, what do they call that?
The price tag depressants, but I forget
the actual technical term. Maybe one girl,
this type,
this type of antidepressant on many people
with many formulations causes people
to go limb,
but some girl calls up and says she had
like 150 orgasms and then doctor drew
was apparently pushing this stuff and
they paid him a quarter of a million
dollars to do that and he didn't really
necessarily disclose that they paid him
all this money allegedly.
But I would like to see that girl do 150
orgasms whenever I, that'd be so hot.
That bitch sounds crazy, but you
never know when people are trolling.
She's calling loved line manage
could be totally trolling.
I mean there's people completely pretend
that they have something wrong with
them when they don't feel it. For sure.
They get a lot of people that are,
that are legit, but they must, we
know all the trolls and the Internet.
You don't think that people are compiling
some troll footage on Loveline can
check out her mattress,
see if there's any stains.
I'm sure if he had that much orgasms,
there's going to be a lot. Yeah,
that's what you would do. Well, I'm not
sure if I believe your story, ma'am.
So let me come to your house and deeply
investigate your claim by going in your
fucking bedroom and examining your
mattress. You do you even hear yourself?
Do you ever look at your old mattress?
I just got a new mattress.
That's how I know I took
off my shirt rose. It was,
it looked like fucking sh brown drip
like a look like a lot of liquids and
stepping in there with
like some blood spots.
You know a lot of different colors.
Easy over here.
Well they say that your,
your mattress actually gets
heavier with human skin cells.
Like you know your matches when you buy
it as like x amount of weight and then
you have it for a couple of
years and it's like heavier.
That's creepy as shit man.
We're pros. We're gross man.
We,
that's what dust is most of is our skin
are creepy fucking skin sheets on your
bed. You know, it's key. This time around.
I actually scrubbing everything
this time around. I got something,
it's like these waterproof sheets where
you put it around your whole entire
mattress and it locks it into nothing
and get in there and it's on the outside,
it feels like nice cough cushion and then
you put your regular sheets on top of
that and it's wholly will
make that shit not happened.
You know like the stains and like the
all the dust and skin and bugs and it
makes it like waterproof pretty
much to him. She goes out the code.
A lot of proof sheets I think there. Oh,
so does it feel like slimy underneath,
you know, slip around now
because it's like, it's like
on the outside it's like a,
I was like that bird like
a fabric I real soft.
Like almost like teddy bear on the,
okay.
I would hate it back in my single days
I would hate it when girls would have
like silk, like periods and shit during
the sex and like you just ruined my,
the shit went all the way through
to the mattress. I know. It sucks.
It sucks man. Everyone
has, not everyone, but uh,
I'm sure you've had a mattress or two that
had like all sorts of stuff. You gotta
you gotta you gotta put a towel down son?
Yeah.
Or they say, no, I'm done. I stopped
yesterday and then you fuck them.
It starts back up and then you have a
girl that works and just don't you feel
embarrassed for the girl though.
Do you ever actually get upset at a girl
if she has her period? No. No, no, no.
I don't. I don't, but I
don't like when it's messy.
I've always been so happy that someone
was willing to fuck me. I'm like, oh,
well you made a mess.
You shit the bed. Wow.
Let's just clean that up
and not worry about that.
Is it different than blood
all over my dick that isn't,
I guess washed that shit up.
There's just now I got stains on shit.
There's a difference between
that. Like where you know, you,
you fuck them in it's accidently blood
or when they just like know that their
period was near and they'd like, no, I
just want to sleep naked. And you're like,
come on. That's not taking responsibility
for having an open wound, you know? Oh,
does that, does it leak out while they're,
while they're sleeping? Yeah, I guess so.
I mean that's it. That's how it leaks
out when their panties, you know,
earlier design. Yeah.
Fucking crazy design.
Like for one time every month your,
your shit just sort of doesn't happen.
What if our dicks blood like just peed
blood all the time. It's just strange.
It's just a strange thing that happens
when you're getting ready. Yeah.
Just sheds the inside of your Dick
Sheds. Honey, would you blow me?
But I'm on my period to start by doing.
Some girls would like it.
They want the extra protein of the blood.
Golf chicks did want to blow you
when you were on your period.
It'd be really hot.
Yeah. We're lucky at a lot of ways,
man. We'd love to, we don't give birth.
I've always said that men had their dicks
explode like a girl's pussy was to go
through damage. Or if you had
to get us Aserion to have a kid,
how many kids would there
be if dude's got pregnant?
We had to have a sincerity and every time
we gave birth, I feel like, go Connie,
I don't know. I had to work. I've got no
fucking time to have this, this hereon.
Okay, I can't take me out of work
for a month. Jesus fucking Christ,
glorify Dick's exploded. Imagine the
does it would want to carry a baby.
That was the two options.
You can either go the old school where we
did loads and they never used it again.
That almost be almost be gay,
right?
Well maybe that would be the way that
they would prevent men from having more
than one child.
The child
would come out of your deck and so you,
you impregnate,
you have sex with a woman and a, you know,
you feel like you're impregnating her,
you shoot a load out, but it actually
goes back inside of you from the woman.
Something that drops a
fucking hatch in there.
You get the egg from the moment of
plants inside your body. Maybe that's it.
There you go.
And so when the baby comes out,
it comes out through your deck
and boom, that's it. One kid.
That's all you get raised
it, right? Wow, that's great.
That's a crazy idea.
That actually is probably a good idea.
That might be the best way to save the
world. We've got to reengineer people.
So the babies come out of
men and their dicks explodes
and that'll put everything in perspective.
There will only be a thousand
people on earth though.
Probably not even a thousand, right?
Be like a hundred a hundred feet.
Little fishing villages scattered
throughout the world with dudes.
It's blown out.
Dicks
are you shit out a baby. That'd be
awesome. They figure out a way to,
to plan a baby inside your,
um, large. Be so selfish. You'd be like,
you really want to shit on your baby.
That's ridiculous.
Then you just ruin the wedding.
It's so ridiculous that you've made a
shit that's realistic, man. Come on.
What did you used to have a
sketchy road call? Shit baby.
My friend Amir had a really
funny joke about, and my friend,
he was like real like
deadpan. He's like, yeah,
my friend got his girlfriend
pregnant from anal sex.
The baby looked like shit.
Somebody just said that exact
same joke the other day.
That was the premise of shit, baby.
Anybody. It's not like the most brilliant,
you know, original thought. It was just
the way mirror did it. It was very funny.
So funny. James Lemur was his name in
Boston. He had a, he had a different name.
His real name is Amir, but he,
he was like a very Jewish name,
but he changed it to James' name.
Shit baby was about,
um,
the opening scene is some girls getting
plowed in the ass really hard dude.
Nuts pulls out, jumps in the shower,
she's laying there face down,
huffing and puffing.
The camera's zooms in on the butt and
you see come dripping out of the butthole
end of the pussy.
Right Tom.
So then she gets pregnant and
uh, she, when she has the baby,
like woven into the baby's
DNA is that smell of feces.
So it was just, it just, that's
the problem with the baby.
The baby just got just stinks.
Like shit,
there's flies around
the baby at all times.
So this chick brings up
this kid as a documentary.
This Chad brings up this kid that
smells like shit. Like what would,
I mean everyone should go,
she's spraying on the end of
the basketball everywhere.
Just constantly flies everywhere.
Smell is a weird thing.
It's really weird that we all accept
that there's some invisible shit.
Then we can take in with a hole in our
face. You know, it's kind of weird,
you know, the invisible. That's awesome.
Like when you walk into a,
a good burrito place and you
smell the Mexican food cooking. Oh
yeah. Fogo perfect example. Smelled
that meat as it's coming by. It's weird,
man. It's like, it's a weird
invisible thing, but your,
your nose can pick it up.
You can even smell where things like if
you pick up your underwear and go to the
crotch, you could smell
like that. You've worn it.
You could smell your body on that.
That's crazy.
Some invisible identity
shit that you leave behind.
Nothing's worse than human shit for sure.
That bad pussy and feet,
bad feet. That's it.
Yeah, that's right. And corpse. Anything
that's trying to keep you away from it.
It's interesting how that works.
I mean it's your,
your brain is really fine tuned to like
get away from anything that's really bad
for you and so you sounds an alarm when
you're in the presence of a decaying
corpse. All those chemicals set an
alarm through your system and you just,
you just immediate, nobody likes it. Yeah.
The thought of eating that corpse
is impossible. Some people,
there's a small percentage of people
that do like it. Yeah. Oh most.
Some people like, you know,
all sorts of weird things.
The smell of a dead rotting body can
imagine that if you knew somebody that
actually liked that and the confession
that like say I don't, I don't,
I've never told anybody before
but I fucking love running flash.
I think that that could be
possible like for, for anything.
I mean I think there's people that are
nutty enough to get in love with anything
they can get in love with
cutting their own finger.
What's the latest with the Mat Salts?
Give me the latest.
I know you know what the would pass
salts are and this is what it's been
explained to me is that you can take a
drug that's an illegal drug and all you
have to do is change certain molecules
in that drug and then you release it.
Like you add like a salt to it and you
release it as bath salts and you say not
for human consumption,
but people know what it actually is
and you can go and buy it and you're
essentially buying like a
sort of a designer drug.
You're,
you're buying something that hasn't been
classified and they're really intense
and they, they have really bad
profiles. Like if you look at like,
um,
there's a erowid.org that shows
a lot of trip reports and uh,
whatever the compound that they're
calling, you know, there's,
there's several different types.
I think I might be wrong about that.
I don't think bath salts is
necessarily just one thing.
I think there's been more than one,
but someone please on Twitter,
correct me if I'm wrong.
So I think it's a,
it's a problem of they can do
that with several different drugs.
I think they can do that with things
that are illegal. Just change, you know,
if meth is illegal, change
math. If a ecstasies illegal,
change it a little bit here, change a
little bit, add a little bit here and in,
and they're doing it without any real
research as to what kind of an effect
these hardcore drugs are going to have
in this sort of hybrid form. You know,
this is just letting people
take this stuff. You know,
and people this, you know,
I don't know how many people are taking
it and losing their fucking mind,
but a few people seem to me,
it seems to be a good one.
It seems to be one that's
kind of quite a fucking kick.
Mec Chris has a new song about
taking bath salts and it's awesome.
Did he do it? Did he actually
take power? No, no, no, no, no,
but it's just it really addicting.
And what's one of the songs?
What did you hear it? You're just
singing it all the time. It's like about,
you know, doing bath salts and wanting
to eat your face off. It's great.
But that Dude Chris, they said that
they see Chris. Yeah. Is he funny?
Is that funny rapper? Yeah, but they
said that dude wasn't on Bass Hall.
It's the guy that a bit
the guard's face off.
They're saying now that he
was on marijuana reefer as,
yeah. Okay. Do you want to
reveal it now? No, dude.
That's way worse than reefer madness.
Madness propaganda.
They never said he'll eat someone's
face. Right. That's worse.
Back in the thirties I was
saying that if you smoked weed,
you'd go crazy and shoot people.
Well, they didn't really have the,
they didn't have the capacity to
test for this hidden metabolite.
They tested for things that were, they
were known and that's what the, uh,
the argument is against it.
That they didn't,
I don't know if that's correct either.
By the way,
that's not the illegal in Vegas. So if you
want to maybe do it this weekend, guys,
is it legal in Vegas?
Yeah. Jesus Christ. Wow.
I hope they take care of that.
I don't know what that is.
That's a scary thing to me though.
You know,
and the fact that these people
are breaking down medical
marijuana dispensary as
while they're selling bath salts,
but other people were there still on
bath salts. What's a funny set picture?
So me on the message board,
we throw it up on some chick's pussy
[inaudible] who is slain and
Jack Tillo slain in charts.
Hilarious. I pick, I'm going to, I'm
going to tweet this pic real quick. Wow.
That's a hard word. Slain in jealous.
Hilarious. That's a great pick.
That's hilarious. That's the
Internet for you folks. Do you?
Internet will always be on shit like that.
That's awesome.
I'm about to tweet the pictures so
you know what we're talking about.
I'll retweet it like, did you see this
girl with her Nice Muffler? It's like,
Brian, do you want a podcast right
now? And you've walked looking at porn.
You're getting distracted. If I was
your boss, oh wait, it's the message.
Don't be staring at plus corporate
website. Which headquarters?
You see Ted yet? Anyone? No, I have
not seen 10 yard. It's awesome.
I heard it's one of the funniest movies
of all time. All right. It's hilarious.
I don't love it.
I never fell in love with it,
but it was so great the whole time
that I love. I love. I like it a lot.
Meaning there's nothing wrong with it.
It's when it's a great movie.
I recommend to everybody, but I
never did the extra where, Oh my God.
I went to buy a Ted Teddy
bear now in like, you know,
like a freak out by Ted shirts
and stuff. Bear. I never got,
I never got to that level of just,
it was pretty good thing into a six year
old was pretty good. Fucking crazy loud.
Like teddy bear level. Like I bet
the SQL be a million times better.
What are you talking about?
Why would you say that you're just
spouting off crazy shit today.
I if it four and a half stars. Oh five
Brian, that's pretty fucking good. Yeah,
that sounds good. Awesome.
You know something fun.
I probably kept him off
the podcast right there.
There was a couple parts. This
asshole. Here's a couple of parts.
So it was red band and we're like,
they remade a wreak make
like it was weird. Oh,
check it out. They don't say
anything. Don't say a word. You fuck.
I'm going to a director's cut.
I think it would be better.
Maybe it is the director Scott. Fuck.
Do you know? Maybe I, yeah. Yeah.
You don't know. There probably
is. There's mushrooms in it
is young cocaine today. Something's
going on. I Dunno man. Yeah,
like asleep and electrocuted.
I've been,
what was the last summer to olive
garden? Last Sunday. Be Honest.
Seriously, and I Sunday
last Sunday. All right.
That's what you want to stick to the
story and I went with somebody that it's
never been there before and it was
their first time and they had prejudged.
I don't really want to talk about the old
guard. Are you fucking kidding me here?
The fuck is wrong.
We have a couple of hours to do this.
Don't let this guy sit and talk
about breadsticks. How about them?
Dodgers don't make me bring in Joey Diaz.
What the fuck dude,
why would you see then I
said what you like karate.
Can I say one thing about the opposite?
It's kind of weird.
Now they're combining red lobster
and olive garden test market city,
so you can actually choose between
both menus. Isn't that cool?
Because they're like going bankrupt.
We're trying this thing.
You haven't seen the new joined karate?
No, I haven't seen it. That's great.
Is that he kills it because he talk about
the upcoming fights. Oh, pull it up,
put it on. Well, how do you find
that? It's 10 planet Kush episode.
Uh, 25 10 flag Kush. Episode 25
this weekend's going to be insane.
That rematch that we matches the biggest
rematch of all time in my opinion,
as far as like fights and I want
to see this is in my opinion,
the biggest rematch of all
time. So greatest fight of
all time. Are you kidding?
I'm so Loretta's fights
rematches generally.
Cause that was something crazy.
What's up 39 you said 10th Planet Kush.
25 25 Joey crushes it. Yeah.
This, this is the biggest rematch
ever, right? Yeah. Here it is.
If you wait following at mad flavor, go
fuck yourself. This is under a twister.
Eddie on Youtube, by the way.
That's where I found God. Volume.
It's going to start.
There it is.
That's good.
Headquarters.
It's 192 fucking degrees out there,
but I'm going to give you a preview,
but UFC one 48 I'm giving
you the poly or the year.
Everybody's complaining going to win.
[inaudible] Anderson Chair.
I don't give a fuck.
We're just trying to get paid bitches
with a fucking Paul like first up Chad
Mendez. Who was he fighting
guys? What the fuck?
What Cory Mckenzie, whatever.
Whatever's fucking Cody. Mackenzie.
I guess my mad Chad Mendez
coming off a fucking Nian Brazil.
Let me tell you something.
If you got a brill,
a knee and Connecticut and a knee in
Brazil, two different fucking stories.
He's coming back. He's going to beat
up. I'm Mackenzie. That's one lock.
My second lock is Damien
Maia against Yum yum. Cam.
Damien's dropping down the fucking
one 70 he's a Jujitsu maniac.
All over sudden he wants to be Muhammad
Ali. He's going to go up against young,
young Kim,
a black belt in judo flip
and motherfuckers like
cow per region before the
fucking painkillers.
Amazing. You understand me?
He's going to get fucking van in
Maya at one 70 and he's done duck.
So that's my parlay is yum.
Yum Kim.
I guess y'all can make money or you want
to fucking play games with the other
buddies. Now you're saying Joey, what
about Tito against far as Griffin,
10 fucking psychics under strip. Can't
pick that one. You understand me?
All I know is I'm watching some interview
show with Tina. I love him to death.
He's a hall of fame and they're
like, Tito, why are you quitting?
Why the fuck is he quitting? He's
won one in six. You understand me?
It's time to go cup soccer. That's all
I can tell you. I love you the deck.
Congratulations. You and forest
Whitaker. I love the fucking fight,
but I wouldn't bet you
motherfuckers at all.
Another fight on the card is commonly
the flying fucking master of kicks on
Cinemax versus the comeback.
The leg. What's his name?
Patrick fucking coat. Tank
fighting. I'll come back in.
The UFC slipped that one in. So you've
got Kung Lee against fucking Damon.
Who's he fighting? Oh, he's
fighting. Uh, Patrick Hotel.
The one fucking legged man from Canada.
And I'm going with Patrick coattail apps
a squeezing. Now you're going to Joey.
What about channel? What about,
and I'm going to give it to you.
Fucking straighten daddy. Right?
Channel Center is a fucking champion.
He took it down. This is silver. Whatever.
Anderson silvers are fucking savage.
You're right.
He worked at Mcdonald's.
He was making big macs fucking 15 years
ago. He's angry. He went down to Brazil.
He thought about it and you
hugged this 19 fucking kids.
He's got a bus full of kids,
Anderson, and he's back.
He's going to Las Vegas this weekend.
Let me tell you something, channel.
I love you to death,
but it's all over the shot and
I don't care what the odds are.
I don't care what fucking, uh,
Kenny Florian says, or Jon,
Anik, I don't give a fuck.
This is going to be ugly.
I'm going with my man,
Anderson Silva to
fucking take it to champ.
The last time he fought bad and he
got him in the fifth fucking around.
They got beat up. Can you imagine
a healthy fucking Anderson Silva?
Take your little fucking panties.
Forget going to the Strip club.
Put It on the Anderson. You got the
fucking Parlay Mendez and who else?
What the fuck people are you all
sleeping here? [inaudible] yum, yum.
Kim Against Cody Mackenzie. Paula. Oh Yum.
Yum Kim against my man.
Fuck
10 plan to take it from that.
Tim is not fighting. Chad Mendez.
Cody Mckinsey's fighting Chad. Man.
Fuck it all up. Motherfuckers right
there. Oh my God, he's so high.
Our apologies to the grade Dong Young
Kim for Joey Diaz messing up his word.
Calling them yum. Yum Kim.
That's uh, that's Kinda rude.
How dare he, I thought it
was hilarious. Pissed off.
Like people are calling them yum.
Yum Kim. Now all over the inner,
what do you think about Damien
Maia dropping down to one 70?
Uh, he's uh, he's going
to be a big one 70.
If he can do it right, it'll be, can do
and be healthy for folks who don't know,
you know, follow MMA. Damien Maia,
is this one of the best Jujitsu
guys to ever enter into MMA?
He's a multiple time world champion. Just
so really killer technical Jujitsu guy.
And he entered into MMA and for awhile
he was strangling a lot of people,
including Chael Sonnen. Uh, he got
Chael Sonnen, a mounted triangle.
Remember that Shit. Hold them on.
Yeah, he uh, he, he took them down.
Remember that?
What the fuck did he use?
Was it a lateral drop?
I think it was a lot drive him off guard
cause child did not think he was going
to take them down.
Yeah.
Didn't think he was going to try
that move. Yeah. He liked lateral,
dropped him and then mounted
triangle. Tim, it was so sweet man.
It was like really the the quickest
I've ever seen shale gets submitted.
It was like when he got taken down
it was like bang, whoop. Oh Shit.
He's caught tap. It was,
it was just his Jujitsu.
Damien Maia when he's on, when he
catches you is so picture perfect man.
He's such a beast and if he's able to
get ahold of guys at one 70 he'll be even
better.
But it's about whether or not this is
healthy and whether or not he could still
take him down at one 70
and there's monsters.
Jake shields guys that he's not
going to be able to take down. Yeah.
I think his Jujitsu, you make one mistake
with Damien. My you're fucked. Yeah.
He's a finisher. He knows how to close
the deal. He catches you in a triangle.
It's oversight. You're not
escaping. He's totally professional.
When it comes to submissions,
I just liked it,
liked it better when he had more faith
in his half guard because you know,
early UFC days he wouldn't hesitate
to pull guard. He pulled guard,
he actually pulled half guard and there's
a big difference between jumping guard,
pulling guard and pulling half guard.
He pulled half guard.
He had a lot of faith in his half guard
in the early, um, early UFC fights,
but he likes to stand more now and he
has totally made a conscious decision not
to pull guard,
not to have that as an option.
And I think you should
reconsider that option.
And look at what Paul Sas is doing.
He's just, when Paul Sas fights,
he's completely taken the dude's wrestling
and striking out of the mix because
if Paul Sas is fighting a Combo
fighter who's a world champion,
kickboxer Killen and
k one, and he's a, uh,
a Olympian rustler to him, he's going
to pull guard anyway, so he'd come,
he takes those two, uh, um,
skill sets out of the picture.
I'm not saying that you should
just go out there and pull garlic,
but you should have a guard like
Paul Sassy should pull guard. Yeah.
And Damien Maia does have a
guard by Paul says he does.
He has a very dangerous guy.
Damien Maia is, God is amazing.
He just is chosen not to have
that as an option anymore.
And I think I always call it the third
option and it should be an option in your
game.
You should.
What do you think keeps him from
getting hit on the ground? I think, um,
well a lot of people think
that they say they're,
that they don't work on their guard
techniques are there half guard.
They don't refine it.
Because in MMA when you're on your back,
you're losing. That's what that's
like. The thing to say about that,
and professional fighters,
a lot of them think that this way that if
you're on your back, you're losing. Yes.
But you're also losing. If you're on
your feet getting tattooed with punches,
you're also losing their,
so what's the difference if you're losing
on your feet and lose it on the ground,
at least if you have a
really good half guard game,
you have a really good full guard game.
You have a really dangerous rubber guard.
If you've got a lot of heat off your back,
there is a way for you to win off
your back. Instead of, I'm on my back,
I'm losing. There's no hope
if Aoki, he's on his back.
There is hope for him.
When you remember when Jason Day fought
Alan Belcher and just held him and
rubber guard and elbowed them,
you could just do that.
You could just hold it a dude in
mission control and throw elbows.
It's been proven that it's very effective.
It's out there. The evidence is there,
but just, you know, we just got
to get wicked good at it. I mean,
they're like a guy who's going to
pull it off as a guy like Vinny,
Vinny Magalhaes. He's going to
be able to pull it up. If it it,
if he could get the fight to the ground
because vending is not the greatest
restaurant on the planet and he's not
the greatest striker on the planet.
He is improving both vastly. He's
working on it and he, he has accepted,
I talked to him personally.
He has accepted that he will pull guard
if he can't take the guy down because
there's only three things you can do in
a fight, and I've said this many times,
there's only three things.
You could stand with a guy,
you could try to take a guy down
or you can pull guard. That's it.
There's no other way to fight. You
fight in her feet, you gotta fight,
you try to take them down or your pull
guard. Most people only have two options.
If they can't take the guy down,
they better be able to beat him
standing or they lost. Just like that.
I wish that the cutting weight was
not in the equation. This bothers me,
but, but this is what I'm talking
about has nothing to do with, wait.
What I'm talking about is having the,
are having strategy ways. Three ways.
The win.
Most fighters only have two ways.
I think the fighter of the future
is going to have three ways to win.
He's going to be a serious striker
and can fucking knock you out.
But if shit ain't going right standing,
he can take you down cause he
has a Olympic Jon Jones. Yeah,
wrestling or if he can't take you down
or if you can't take your opponent down
and he's beating you standing.
If you have a wicked guard,
you have the option to pull guard.
Like Paul Saskatoon,
he wins all his fights by pulling guard.
It's his first option.
I don't agree that it should
be a first option all the time.
I think I would want my fighters to get
as good as possible with our striking
and the wrestling. If you could take
a guy down, don't fucking pull guard.
Take his ass down. If you can beat
him standing, don't take them down.
Keep standing with them. You're
fucking, you own this guy.
But if the god of my fighters getting
own standing and it can't take the guy
down, you have to pull guard.
That's the only thing you can do.
And the guys that are missing an easy
thing to pull off. It's not easy.
You just don't sit. I'm not talking
about specialists, Paul Sas opponents.
I know what he's looking to do.
Pulling Guard has become very complex.
You've got to understand the
difference between jumping guard,
jumping guard is when you're against the
fence like Stefan struve did. He was,
he had his back against the fence,
so it was really easy because he
was being pinned on the fence.
Really easy to just jump up and
go Koala on him. He jumped guard,
pulled them down and went right to an
arm bar. It works. There's an option.
There's a way out.
Anytime you're on your back in a fight,
any all fighters out there,
anytime you've been on your back
and had a guy on a full guard,
you actually had an opportunity to beat
that guy right there. That's an odd,
it's not, don't look at that last
time. Dinny Magallanes guard,
Shinya Aoki Guard.
There's only a few people who've really
taken the time to master fighting off
your back because most fighters coming in,
they listened to their instructors
and the instructors say, Oh,
if you're on your back,
you're losing. Well,
especially if you mean you get on your
back with a fucking big Russell that you
can't hold onto it like a Jake
Ellenberger type character.
It's going to ground and
pound your fucking face off.
That's a scary spot to be.
You know,
currently you have to have,
it's not that scary if
you're Vinnie Magallanes.
He wants you to be on top and start being
aggressive and start punching Fabrizio
over doing exactly what we're doing.
Ryan Parsons was talking about when
they train ground and pound for ratios,
like none of this stuff works on him.
Was Guard is so good.
He's always like feed on your
hips and feet on your shoulders.
The one dimensional fighter we already
know, they're gone, they're gone.
There are retired or any one
dimensional and then you've got like two
dimensional fighters.
There's guys that can have pretty good
stand up and there were good wrestlers.
Jiu Jitsu ain't that good.
Those guys aren't going to last you.
That you have to be really good at all
aspects of the game. Striking, wrestling,
top game, Jujitsu and bottom and game,
Jujitsu. You have to be good at all,
all those levels. I think in the
future right now it's, you know, um,
it's,
it's not um,
a popular view too in the MMA world to
really focus and Polish up your bottom
game. That's not a thing you want to do
because that's like admitting you already
lost. That's like admitting that you're
wrestling is not going to be good enough
admitting that you're not
a fucking fierce striker,
admitting that you're afraid to
stand and strike with someone.
That's what a lot of guys,
a lot of guys want to go out there and
there's Jujitsu guys and there's a bunch
of them. I don't want to name names,
but a lot of guys go out there.
They're Jujitsu world champions
and they want to stand and trade.
They want to be kickboxers now, you
know? And it's of weird. And then, yeah,
there's a lot of them and it's,
I think this is my experience.
I think that to get over that,
most Jujitsu fighters,
a lot of them generally have a fear of
doing standup because they're not that
good at it.
It's not their sport.
Now they're thrust into a kickboxing
sport where they're not that good.
They spent their whole life on the ground.
So there is an element of fear because
you can get knocked the fuck out.
So to conquer that fear and to fucking
Stanwood professional strikers and get
some fucking licks in and take the shots,
I can see that empowering that and making
them feel like a fierce warrior with
like, fuck pulling guard. This is awesome.
I'm actually standing with professional
strikers taking their shit and knocking
dudes out every now and then, fuck yeah,
I'm standing. I can see them, you know,
really liking that rush, you know,
that feeling. I conquered fear,
you know what I mean?
It feels good.
Like they don't give a fuck about getting
hit. I think it makes them feel good.
It's not the best strategy to win a fight,
but for their own personal empowerment
and it's, I'm sure it's glorious,
you know, I can see that. You know
when George George l goes out there,
he's a black belt in Jujitsu.
He fucking loves the trade.
He loves that Shit. It makes them
feel like a fucking savage, you know?
I can see that. I'm like
okay, I understand if fucking
having a good time. Yeah.
Cause that's takes a lot of
bottles of the actually do it.
It's like base jumping. You know,
you can only do that for so long.
You can only take so much. It's not
easy. It's not an unlimited resource.
So back to Damien Maia,
I think if you're listening out there,
I loved it when he used to pull half
guard. If you could take the guy down,
take the guy down, stay on
top. That's not happening.
Maybe it's going to be healthy and
fast or one 71 70 or make them faster.
Then he said he will not hesitate
pulling guard if he can't.
If he can't take the guy down, he, he'll
try always try to take the guy down.
But if he can't, he won't hesitate any.
And that gives him a lot of confidence.
He talks to me and that gives him
conference one way or the other.
I'm going to drag the fight to the
ground and bring them into my world. No,
no longer is he gonna
pretend to be a kickboxer.
Did you see Brian Ebersol's fight
with Tj Walberger? Yes. Yes.
Brian Aerosol is hard to
choke. Man. That guy's weird.
Even though Tj Walberger lost,
I think he has a lot of
potential and he looked great.
He just needs to tighten up a lot of
shit to keep going and keep polishing his
game. But as guard look dangerous as
hell ever saw is really hard to tap.
There's something going
on with that guy man.
Cause like he talks about like
the myth of the Guillotine.
Like people can't tap him
with a good team. You know,
I don't know what his deal is.
He might have large a orders
in his neck or something. Yeah.
Or maybe he's just been grappling for so
long that he could just fight that shit
off. You know? Maybe he knows
how to fight that shit off,
but he doesn't tap to give teens. He
says, he says gay teens are a myth.
I wonder if he's a freak.
I think Marcello can tap them though.
Marcello's he'll give it to you because
Marcello's guillotine the Marcella team.
I think it's the best choke in
the game. It's a May. It's proven.
The research is out there. If you really
want to find the best choke in the game,
you should know as many jokes as possible.
But the best one for sure,
the research, the evidence, it's
all out there. The Marcella tin,
the way Marcella does his
guillotines study that shit.
Cause what is the main difference?
He's not choking you like
it sound like a blood choke.
He's smashing your throat so you tap real
quick. They're really quick. Taps is,
if you've got a gun
arm and guillotine you,
you might have to crank it maybe
1520 seconds, maybe 30 seconds.
You're twisting and maybe 35 seconds,
Bam. He finally gives up in tops. Right.
You know the Marcella
team comes in a flash,
your throat gets smashed
and you start tapping.
It's a different kind of guillotine.
It's the most effective
guillotine out there by far.
There's it put guys to sleep still,
even though it's smashing the throat or
is it just all pain? From my experience,
people are just tapping from
the pain. Huh? Sometimes.
But it is kind of a a choke where
you can't breathe. Right. You know,
you're throwing it to being smashed. You
can't breathe. You've got to top quick.
So if you can't breathe
because your throat,
your throat is getting blocked. Do you
fall asleep? Maybe you still fall asleep?
I don't know. I don't know. Yeah. I, I've,
I've never seen a guy who
had been more impressed with,
with his choke defense than
ever saw. He's crazy. Yeah.
He doesn't even seem uncomfortable.
He just gives, his head,
gets all red and he guts it out and
then he's on top throwing bombs.
It seems like he just, he's really hard
to choke. Yeah. He's a warrior man.
Tough fucking dude,
man.
I'm a big fan of Brian ever saw and a
guy who's not afraid of getting choked
like that, he can put himself into
all kinds of weird situations.
It's very strange.
You know,
I'm a fan of anybody who has the balls
to throw to just do a cartwheel kit. Oh,
you know what I mean? How else
people come on. That's, this is the,
this is the kick that, uh, people
thought it was a fake fight. You know,
he got in like a situation
when the commission people
thought that he had a fake
fight.
Like it was pro wrestling.
Like they didn't believe that you
could actually kick somebody like that.
That's crazy. That shit has
a lot of power. That's like
a, a wheel kick ass kick,
you know, like, uh, in more
powerful than that really,
because it's good gravity going in it.
What kind of kick?
What's it called to cartwheel.
Kick cartwheel. Okay. Yeah,
that's what I'm, uh, on. Um,
Steve Genom, uh, was Harold Howard tried
it on Steve Genom. Yeah. But that shit,
he came, he left c three was it
three came out and cartwheel kicked.
It was a legit technique in like a
karate point fighting and, and different,
you know, I think that was
probably like the root of it.
It was karate I think was the root of
it. But it's, it fucking works, man.
If you learn how to do it right,
you could nail somebody ever sells
knock guys out with it. He tried it.
He tried it on a Tj.
He's a wild motherfucker.
He's got to fight again in Calgary.
They just added him onto a,
to that car I think.
So He'd be fighting like you just
a few weeks after his last fight.
What do you think about Tito forest?
I think it's a good,
it's good when guys are,
uh,
they've had a great careers and they're,
you know,
probably to the end of those great
careers and they're fighting each other.
I like that.
What,
what gets me concerned is when I see
like one of these guys that's been in the
game a long time is a legend of the game
and he's fighting like a top young lion
that, that I always feel
like, Ooh, I don't really, I
don't want to you like those.
Yeah. Cause it's like a rocky
story. They could pull it out.
I remember rocking 65 when it came back.
Yes. But there's some guys that, you know,
they cross a threshold where you don't
want, you don't want to see them get hurt.
Like they crossed the threshold
where you see them, you know,
get laid out a couple of times
and you're like, all right, I'm,
I'm not really in the scene. This
dude get hurt any further. You know,
especially by some young
killer, you know, you see some,
some young dude who just
just has lightening fast
strikes and just comes in and
lights him up.
What do you think about young,
young Kim and don young and dumb
mine? Kim, what do you think?
I think Kim is getting really good
with his kickboxing is uh, you know,
his movement and his feet is way
better. Don Young Tim, he's got,
um,
who did he rock?
You rock somebody with a like a jumping
front kick to the face and then finished
him off. What the fuck
was a, I don't remember,
but Damien Maia striking
is getting better as well.
It is not afraid to throw down.
Well he and his striking is pretty decent.
He hurt. Um, uh, um, uh, Mark
Munoz. He tagged Mark Munoz.
I think you were really surprised
the shit out of them. It's,
there's a couple of Brazilians that are
turning into illegit Stryker's a Damien
Maia and fraud buddies or
we're doomed. Yes. Yeah.
For breached over doing this
crazy watching guys blossom,
right? Yeah. He's got a,
um, I mean for Reesey over dooms
got like a real kickboxing game now.
Throws nasty knees, leg kicks. He calmed.
I'm that dude with an uppercut, you know,
a clean upper cut. He's dangerous
guy. That's a big dude, man.
When you stand next to Fabricio Werdum
his fucking feet are like that big.
His hands are, but that's
a real heavyweight. He's
saying motherfucking hands,
you know, and press the fuck out of
me, Charles on Olivera man. God Damn,
that is a true savage.
Right.
Then Sean Pearson was the guy that don't
young Kim hit with a jumping front kick
in the face and Sean Pearson's
fucking good man. And you know he's,
he's got a victory over Nate Diaz. He's
got a victory over a mirror set. Dolla.
He's fucking good man.
Don Young Kim is good and he's no joke
and he's not scared to go to the ground
either. He's strong as fuck. He's a
really good judo guy. Real good defense.
You know, so cause he'd be, it could
be or it could be a submission man.
It could be a submission.
They could go to the ground and Danny
Meyer might just lock them up and one 70
if he can come in healthy,
you know,
if he weighs like a healthy one 85
one 90 or something, come fight time.
That's going to be weird to say.
But how old is Damien?
He's probably in his mid thirties
probably 30 to 35 or something like that.
I should find out before
I talk a lot about,
cause that has an effect also on cutting
a big amount of weight this late in
your career. It's going to be interesting
to see what it looks like it's sending.
I'm sure he's a smart guy though.
If he's doing anything,
I'm sure that he's doing it the right way.
34 if he's doing anything,
you know he spends a lot of time
training with a lot of wrestlers and I'm,
I'm sure they're going to give him like
the exact right way to do it and you
know he's not,
he's such a bright guy.
I would assume that he would absolutely
do it the correct way and he would only
not, I mean it must have made
some, some test runs, but I,
I have a split feelings on shit like that.
I just think it's so unhealthy when
dudes cut a shit load of weight.
I was just like, man, I don't
think you should cut that
much weight. It's so crazy.
It's so,
it just seems so unhealthy.
It seems like there's a
point of diminishing return
than a lot of guys cross
over. You know, I think you get to around
like eight, 10 pounds, five pounds,
something like that. That's nothing.
That's good. That's fine. That's fine.
That's barely even gonna hurt you.
You're going to be fine. You know, you,
you go back and refuel. But when dudes
are cut in 25, 30 pounds like there,
Anthony Johnson and that it coming in
like weighing almost 200 pounds and
they're finding it one 70.
That's of crazy. It's weird.
It's like, how do you, uh,
how do you f how do you stop that though?
How do you tell people that they, uh,
they can't do that anymore? Well, if you
can make it, then that's your spot. Yeah.
You know, that's where they should be.
If you could make it, that's your spot.
I know,
but what a weird way to do business.
Like everybody has to almost
kill themselves the day
before we're going to fight.
Everybody has to literally starve to
the point where you're really unhealthy.
Look terrible.
There's a lot of guys to step on the
scale 24 hours before a big fight and they
don't look good at all. You know, it's
crazy. Who knows that more than you? Yeah.
Or there's guys like Bj Penn who would
choose to fight at one 70 and he doesn't
even really weigh one seven he
would weigh like one 66 you know,
and Bj fought like Matt Hughes,
I think he was like one 66 he's been
as low as like one 64 and he's fighting
welterweights you know, is this
that way to do it too. I mean,
Frankie Edgar one lightweight title,
you know,
that way by being a real hundred 55 pound
dude fighting dudes who are, you know,
probably like one 75 maybe
come python maybe even. Yeah,
I mean gray Maynard was a big dude.
He's thick as fuck man. You know,
I don't know how much great cuts,
but he looks big. He's like,
gets to be two 30 during off season.
It didn't like Oberg said he gets
to like 200 or something though.
He's been to probably probably like Joe
Stevenson used to hover around 200 for
launch. She cut down to 55
same thing with Chris Brennan.
Did you see Joe Stevenson? He left
the EOC and they just lost that dude,
Dakota Cochran,
the guy who had been in a,
he had like some sort of
a career and a gay porn.
He thought Justin Lin said yeah.
Undercard and you know,
you don't know this whole
thing about tough. Yeah,
he was on the ultimate fighter and he
had a, it needed some money in this past.
So he did some gay porn and
they let him on the show. Okay.
And I thought that was a, I thought that
was cool. I was like, alright. You know,
like why not man let the kid on the show,
why wouldn't you let him on the show?
Isn't a show all about like trying
to get your shit together. I mean,
how many of the guys that are
on the show have been in jail?
How many of you guys on the jail,
the show been in jail for assault?
Is it had been any, I don't
know. It might not been any.
It probably wouldn't allow you to do.
Right.
They'd probably like make sure that
they didn't get responsible for anybody.
That was dangerous. I don't even know
the answer to that question, but,
so the dude had a little prominence past.
It's in the past now. Unfortunately.
This is a video of it and they let him
on the show. Oh, I think that's cool.
But he didn't make it and he lost.
But he's good man. He's fucking good.
He's real good. He beat Joseph.
Fuck Joe Daddy up, dude.
Fuck Joe Daddy upstanding then caught
them on the ground and got them in a rear
naked and finished him. Wow, dude. And he
had, he had his back a couple of times.
He fucked Joe up, man. He's good. He's
good. He's explosive. He's really fast.
Who did he lose two on the
ultimate fighter? I don't
know, Brian. All right. Sure.
He may have gotten hurt. I think
he, I think you're right. Yeah.
I think you're right. Maybe it's
the last season, right? Yeah,
because I saw the last
season. It was good. Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck happened
to him. So we should look it up.
Are Chryslers and the show
starts tonight at nine.
We're talking about it and my son
trip flip. He's watching right now.
He says he's a sweetie.
I'm
trying to find out
what about, so all of a sudden, what
do you think we think's going? Go down.
I mean anything could happen really.
We can see the exact same fight again
and this time son and pulls it off and
stays out of trouble.
Um,
or maybe Anderson Silva has got to the
point where it's really hard to take down
now it's not,
it's having a hard time taking her down.
Maybe it takes them down once or twice,
but it's the third round
and he's having a hard time.
He's forced to strike with silver
and silver. It takes them apart.
Or we could see Chael Sonnen hurting
Silva standing and then gone right through
them. Anything could fucking happen. You
just don't know. You know, who knows?
Maybe sun and takes.
So the down immediately and silver comes
after him with an incredible guard.
He just,
instead of like being cautious,
like he wasn't in his last find me through
that triangle up in the fifth round,
like go after him right away.
We might see that and he might fucking
tap them in a triangle and 30 seconds.
It could, anything could happen. It's who
the fuck knows this Dakota Cochran Dude.
Uh,
he came in as a late replacement against
Jamie Varner and dominated Jamie Varner
and a titan fighting
championships. Guess he, uh,
he went to a decision over him there and
then he lost on the ultimate fighter or
some dude named James Vick. He lost
a victim. Vic, a split decision.
This was his Wikipedia.
He performed in 16 videos
under the stage name.
Danny fully disclosed this
information to the UFC.
So the FCC said whatever.
They're probably loving it just for the,
just for the interesting angle, but the
dude can fight, forget about all that.
He can fight his ass off.
Jamie Varner Neb justice
blows up.
There's going to be getting out of their
sections when Armenian fighter fights,
there's a section and there all
Armenians, right. You know what I mean?
There's going to be gay sections
probably. That'd be awesome, dude.
I think to do it straight though, you
only did it for money. I'll come on.
Well that's, that's what he says,
but for sure he has it for sure.
He has a big gay following
for sure. For sure. And Dude,
what if they show up in droves?
That'd be awesome.
Would have gay dudes started
entering into fighting
because he's game might have more anger
than your average to all that shit
might be a real mind fuck for a
straight dude. Get beat up by a gay guy.
Like that might be a mind fuck.
Like not only does this guy beat my ass,
he could fuck me and he might want
to. Yeah. You know? Yup. Yeah.
I mean maybe that would have
worked for him. You know,
for a lot of dudes it probably would
for a lot of dudes, he probably would.
You know, when he gets your back, that's
real. Yeah. There's gotta be a stylus.
There's gotta be a style out
there specifically for anal rape.
You know what I mean?
That's the best Jujitsu for sure.
You'd have to have a base in Jujitsu,
but it'd get technical because you'd,
you'd have to pan the arms a certain way.
Pennants needs a certain way to,
to get penetration. It's totally
different drug to hold them in place.
That would be, but it could
be like a, like cop tactics,
like police tactics where there's
Jujitsu in there, but they got the baton,
they got something else going on,
they got handcuffed them.
So maybe you don't have
to handcuff him first.
You have to handcuffs upbeat ideas.
That's,
it seems like a really easiest way,
right
person. Why are you even bring that up?
What a terrible thing to do to a person
that's, that's definitely not using
martial arts for good. Yes, you're right.
I forgot fucked up. I'm sorry.
Have you seen this thing?
I'm going to change gears
completely about, um, these,
um, things that they found,
these portals and the universe,
he's hidden portals between the earth
and the sun. They're totally confused,
but there some sort of a guide
or a shortcut and there's
an opening in the space
or time fields. Yeah, yeah. Whoa.
Yeah. Tweet that shit. Yeah,
it's NASA. It's a NASA funded
researcher and plasma physicist,
Jack Scooter of the
University of Iowa claims.
He has figured out a way to find them
and they're called x points or electron
diffusion regions. And so
there's, there's, you know,
the idea is that there's pathways and
our galaxy, our galaxy isn't just,
it's not just like, you know, you have
to go from here to there. No, you can,
you can actually go in this thing
and it might take you somewhere else.
Like, like, like a real wormhole.
You imagine if we find other wormholes
are just like tunnels that just exist all
over the place and you know how you get,
you know, just drive through the tunnel.
Well,
you could just go through the wormhole
and that's what you do whip and you're on
the other side.
Yeah, man. How about, how about that?
Have you seen a documentary as
the ultimate stoner response and
Morrison did it,
did you ever,
do you know anything about the
Coral Castle in Florida? Yes, I did.
Made some crazy castle.
Brian pulled this up because I don't
understand the science of it and I'm sure
I'm butchering it.
It's NASA discovers hidden portals in
space and put that it's on youtube and
they'll,
it'll explain it like NASA discovers
hidden portals in space and it's on a,
on Youtube, so it'll explain
better what they mean by portals.
But what I'm, the way I'm saying,
and I'm sure I'm fucking it up,
and in my rudimentary understanding of it,
it means that you know,
the universe is not just one flat sort of,
it's not, it's not the same everywhere.
There's a little pathways and shit.
There's a little,
there's things that exist that,
you know,
not just black holes but other things
that will take you through to somewhere
else, which is kind of
nuts. I mean, some day,
some future generation of ours might be
able to actually traverse something like
that. You know what I mean? It's really
crazy to wrap your head around that.
We might figure it out one day how to
navigate through the universe and fucking
go through an actual portal into another
place and it it's hard to wrap your
head around. Yeah, man.
I mean just basic shit like
the earth magnetic field,
you know, and that there are
certain points on the planet,
whether there's hyper activity
presented by science at NASA.
That guy sounds like he gets no pussy.
Bedford theme of science fiction is the
portal an extroardinary opening in space
or time that connects
travelers to distant realms.
A good portal is a shortcut,
a guide,
a door into the unknown if
only they actually existed.
It turns out that they do sort of,
and a NASA funded researcher at the
University of Iowa has figured out how to
find them.
We call them x points or
electron diffusion regions
explains Plasma Physicist
Jack's gutter of the University of Iowa.
They're places where the magnetic field
of earth connects to the magnetic field
of the sun,
creating an uninterrupted path leading
from our own planet to the sun's
atmosphere.
93 million miles away.
Observations by Nassis Themis spacecraft
and Europe's cluster probes suggest
that these magnetic portals open
and close dozens of times each day.
They're typically located a few tens of
thousands of kilometers from Earth with
the geomagnetic field meets
the onrushing solar wind.
Most portals are small and short lived.
Others are yawning.
Vast and sustained energetic particles
can flow through the openings,
heating Earth's upper atmosphere,
sparking geomagnetic storms and igniting
bright polar Aurora's NASA is planning
a mission called MMS.
Short form magnetospheric multiscale
mission due to launch in 2014 just study
the phenomenon bristling with energetic
particle detectors and magnetic sensors.
The force spacecraft of MMS will
spread out in Earth's magnetosphere and
surround the portals to
observe how they work.
Just one problem finding them.
Magnetic portals are invisible,
unstable, and elusive.
They open and close without warning and
there are no signposts to guide us in
notes. Scutter actually, there are
signposts and Scutter has found them.
Portals form via the process of magnetic
reconnection mingling lines of magnetic
force from the Sun and Earth Crisscross
Kross and join to create the openings.
X points are where the
crisscross takes place.
The sudden joining of magnetic fields
can propel jets of charged particles from
the x point creating an electron diffusion
region to learn how to pinpoint these
events.
Scutter looked at data from a space probe
that orbited earth more than 10 years
ago.
In the late 1990s NASA's polar spacecraft
spent years in Earth's magnetosphere,
explained Scutter and it encountered
many x points during its mission because
polar carried sensors
similar to those of MMS,
Scutter decided to see how an x point
looked to polar using polar data.
We have found five simple combinations
of magnetic field and energetic particle
measurements that tell us when we've
come across an x point or an electron
diffusion region,
a single spacecraft properly
instrumented can make these measurements.
This means that a single member of the
MMS constellation using the diagnostics
can find a portal and alert other
members of the constellation,
our mission planners.
Von Thought that MMS might have to,
if you want to hear the whole thing,
go online and check because I'm sure
most of us are not absorbing that.
We're going to have to go back
and listen to that and, and, and,
and read the paperwork on it.
But that sounds fucking crazy.
Finding new things like that in
space. It's like weird. It's so weird.
Like the idea that we already
figured out what was out there up,
there's some new shit. Oh,
here's some, here's some
invisible magnetic portal. OOPS,
here's some new shit.
Did you hear about this?
A new civilization they
discovered that lived, uh, 8,000,
500 years ago, uh, somewhere near Spain.
They found an underwater, they have,
um, like pottery, all kinds of shit.
Apparently this area used to be,
um, used to be above ground, like,
uh, between, uh,
and somewhere between
11,000 and 6,000 years ago,
it's slowly sank away and they,
uh,
they've recovered like
human bones and pottery.
It seems like every other month there's
some new groundbreaking discovery that
pushes back the date of
civilization. It's amazing. You know,
this go Beckley Tampa Bay was like the
first big one and now they're always in
like they found these
concentric rings in the,
in the ocean floor that
they believe is Atlantis.
And I think that's somewhere around
Spain and how there's, there's,
there's all sorts of speculation that
there might have been a fuck load of
civilizations that were like really,
you know,
pretty advanced for the time and we were
living right by the water and they're
gone now the water level changed.
What do you think about that Baltic Sea
to sponsor? There is just a rock crusher.
It's Iraq if you look into it.
Yeah,
I haven't seen any photos that make me
think it's anything other than weird
rocks,
rocks or whatever's going down there and
trying to fuck with it and then turned
power shuts off twice. Yeah, it could
be their equipment sucks at high depth.
You know, it could be the pressure
of the equipment, equipment failed.
Sometimes people look for Shit
to be like something crafting.
I would love it if it
was something crafty,
but I saw the pictures of me like that
shit looks like rocks man. They're like,
well there's a pearl necklace.
It's like scattered rocks.
Like you guys are like reaching
like this is just rocks. I mean,
maybe when you're down there
looking at it eye to eye,
it looks different and maybe there's
some shit that they haven't been able to
photograph yet. The ones you see,
you'd go, oh, whoa, whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
this is a fucking, somebody made
this. Maybe it's possible. But, um,
most,
most of the time I think there's plenty
of shit out there that they could be
looking at are faking their enthusiasm.
They're like way,
no, they're enthusiastic. It
doesn't mean, you know, I dunno.
I Dunno. I Dunno if they're,
they're looking to see something.
I don't know if what they can actually
see as much cooler than the shit they've
shown us.
The shit that they've shown us is like,
you see like this big rock and I don't
know why we're supposed to think that's
special, you know? But why rock
sometimes forming weird forms.
You know, Graham Hancock said it's
just a rock. That's what his real,
his assessment of it was
because a peculiarly or rock,
that's what he believes it is. But you
know, this is just the beginning of data.
No one knows. But the people who were
down there staring at it, you know,
it might be aliens vs Predator fucking
temple and we just a cocky civilization
that used to be above water.
It could be, yeah. Yeah.
I mean how much would
be left of something?
It was underwater for 30,000
years under the ocean.
How much of that chickens jam?
It's like part of some Russian experiment
or something. Yeah. Maybe it's a troll.
Two big troller.
No, no, no. I mean like uh,
some vessel that the Russians were
fucking with like 30 years ago and, right,
right.
I don't think so. I think they're saying
it's a stone. It's a stone structure,
whatever it is, natural
structure, whatever it is.
I believe they're saying it's stolen.
I think there's just some quick Yuliar
like pathways in it and stuff like that.
Just put,
it could be just some weird ass dog
that into it.
I just saw at like maybe a five minute
news clip on the latest dive and they
said they went down to power. All the
power goes off. Then they went back.
Sounds awesome. I was going to write
a script. That's what I would write.
If it was like one of the guys was the
biggest skeptic papa bought. Now he's he,
he can't explain it. He doesn't, he
doesn't want to make a statement,
but he's saying this is not normal.
What is the latest one was the last time
it was a news report. Yeah, look at it.
That's this Baltic Ufo news report.
Yeah.
What's interesting is it's so
sexy to want to want to think.
This is from some other planet.
You know? It's so intriguing.
If we really imagine if we really found
a fucking ship at the bottom of the
ocean and it was just dressed up like a
rock, because that's what you would do.
If you want it to hide your ship,
you make it look like a fucking rock.
I mean they're aliens.
They can come here from another
planet and it has to look like a ship.
It's so stupid.
Maybe they made a fucking alien
spacecraft that looks like rocks,
so when it's on the bottom,
it's just chilling like a rock.
Of course they should be able to alter
their environment or the way they're,
they look to their environment. So maybe
that's what it is. I would love that.
That's the best thing.
That would be the most,
the most fun new story that would
change the world. But I'm not convinced.
New dive details. Photos. See
this look for the new story.
Yeah. There's some photos that uh,
Brian, can you find it to show the rocks?
Well, it's like a BBC thing maybe.
Yeah. I mean it shows it's, it's,
it's interesting man. It's so, you
know, hopefully it's something,
but it might be bullshit.
It might totally be a natural thing
telling me their equipment might suck.
Who knows? But like I said, it's
sexy to think that it's not,
the whole idea of Ufo was the sexiest Yo,
this the sexiest idea that there's
actually going to be something you would
forget your bills.
Forget what the fuck is on TV.
Even if it was like the final season
premiere of the game of Thrones, you know?
Yeah. In the last days in first episode,
you know, final season premier league,
uh, still dude take seeing a Ufo. Remember
if I remember correctly,
and I could be wrong about
David Eick like in his,
in the beginning of his career as being
like a dude who lectures on Illuminati
type stuff. He said some
shit about reptilians and
then a lot of people turned,
uh, that turned them off. They're like,
Fuck David. I cause that Reptilian Guy,
he loses me when he
talks about reptilians.
So then it seemed like he stopped
talking about Reptilians for awhile,
but recently I just saw this seminar
he did and he gets in depth about rope
tows.
He says that all the world
leaders have are being controlled.
Does David Ike I just saw this last week
are being controlled by Reptilians that
are on a different frequency and there
are around them controlling them.
You just can't see them.
They're actually controlling the
world leaders. That's what he thinks.
And he's talking about this in
his lecture. That's amazing.
Amazing that he can do this. Yeah. Um, I
think, uh, I think he's an entertainer.
That's what I think part of what he
does is he's an entertainer. Yeah.
I think he's a, he's a lot like, uh,
there's a few other guys that I don't,
I don't buy a for a second.
He's one of them.
I think he's got some really good valid
that he mixes in with some
crazy shit and he creates,
he creates like a whole cottage industry.
That's what I think. Alex Jones,
Alex Jones was totally against David
Eick for a while because of the reptilian
thing.
It totally against them.
And then he actually became friends with
David Eick and he doesn't really want
to get into it.
He says,
he says that the reptilian thing makes
more sense to them now and they're cool
now. They hated each other. They said,
talk shit on and shuttle. You know?
Now they're cool. They've been cool for a
though, you know Jones is a big sweetie.
Yeah. That's the reality. The reality is
Alex Jones is always a big sweetie. Yeah.
He's one of the cool, clearly as fuckers,
I hang out with a really nice guy.
You know,
people would never believe it.
If you watch his doom and gloom and how
crazy is it that we've partied with him
in Vegas and got hammered with a
hammer and had a great time with him.
He's an awesome guy and
he is not a bad dude man.
He just gets all worked
up and he loves talking.
You know even when the cameras are off
he can talk all that conspiracy talk non
stop non 24 hours and you're never
gets tired of it. I love hearing it.
I got Alex Jones sitting next to
me at Wolf Gang. Puck Illuminati,
the situation he was brought in by
Kennedy in the sixties 1961 operation.
Thundercat.
He'll come up with fucking hit you
with some shit and you're like what?
But a lot of what he's saying is right.
I love Alex Jones, man. I love his shit.
You can't be right all the time.
Everyone's wrong.
And sometimes he's wrong about shit.
You don't discount all the fucking
beautiful info that he has after it.
Yeah, he's going to miss
a lot. You know, you know,
if you're going to judge someone on being
wrong about this or that cause he was
wrong about y two k you can't there,
everyone's wrong about some shit.
You can't be right about everything.
Well, it's the doom and gloom guys.
There's a certain amount of
entertainment to it. You got it.
You got to recognize that much like
Fox News has committed itself to being
conservative.
You know,
he has committed himself to a doom
and gloom and to a certain extent,
that's the problem that I had with
Rupert Murdoch. Rupert Murdoch,
let them know Michael Rupert,
when Michael Gruber was,
was on the show and he would alternate
between thinking that it was going to be
the end of the world or thinking that
people were going to pull it together.
And I think that you can get caught
up in thinking that it's going to,
everything's going to fucking fall apart.
You can get caught up in that.
It's really easy. It's really easy to
just a side. It's all coming to an end.
It's so easy to do, you
know? And I think, uh,
you get caught up in that the whole
world is corrupt and this doom and gloom
everywhere and you,
you caught up in that whole Alex Jones
conspiracy mentality and well a lot of
it's fucking real man. It's
true. We don't live in,
we don't live in a society where the
government is all about the people.
We don't whether you want
to believe it or not.
The way I look at it is I'm
not going go out there and pick
it shit. You know, who knows.
Maybe I'll change my mind a bit effects
if something happens that affects me
personally.
Maybe I'll be out there with a picket,
but one thing we can all do is we can
all use Twitter or Facebook just to make
people aware.
I think everybody is aware and that's
just from Twitter and from Facebook.
If they're aware of what's going
on, I think slowly we change. Yeah.
Because I really think
that, you know, there's,
there is light at the end of the tunnel
from all these conspiracy theories and
all that shit. I think that there is
hope that if the everybody was aware,
and today more than anybody,
any other time in history,
more people are aware that the government
is fucking them than ever before
because of the Internet. So I just think,
let's just keep making people aware.
Just keep pounding them over the head
with the information. Look at the studies,
look at this, look what they're
doing. And if we have it,
some people just do not want to believe
that the government doesn't have our
best interest. You know, they don't
want to believe that they get angry.
If you bring it up there, you don't have
any proof. That's not proof. You know,
there's 1500 engineers and
architects that are banded together.
They've, they've gone out of their
way banning together saying, dude,
Tyler seven was demoed. I
mean, the banding together
and what people say, you know,
how many architects there are,
there's fucking hundreds of thousands,
so 1500 got together.
You know what I mean?
If 1500 architects got together
and petitioned and said,
this house is condemned, it's going to
fall apart. It's dangerous. Would you say?
Uh, it's only 1500 architects.
There's 100,000 of them. No, you'd go,
you'd wait a minute. I'm not moving
into that motherfucker. That's it.
So kind of an unfair comparison because
you're talking about a public event and
when you talk about a public event of the
entire world saw this one public event,
so you're dealing with millions and
millions and millions and millions of
millions of people to get 1500 that
think there's something going on like a
Texan engineers. I'm just saying
1500 crazy people is not unlikely.
I agree. Obviously I've always agreed.
Is something wrong with that, that thing,
it fell down like a controlled demolition.
It's weird.
It's weird that that
doesn't freak people out.
And it's weird that you can't sue the
fuck out of someone who built a building
for you and it catches on fire.
Just fucking kill the houses.
The former head of star wars is coming
out making some serious allegations.
The dig chick, former head of
star wars, is he a scientist?
He's a bunch of show.
He's coming out and saying that prop
based on the evidence based on all the
Shitty knows about, uh, nine 11,
based on all that shit he thinks it
looks like it's probably Dick Cheney was
running all this shit. Wow. He's, that's
what he's saying. He said Dick Cheney
and he shot first forehead of the Star
Wars Program says Cheney may nine, 11,
suspect official version of events.
A conspiracy theory says drills
were to cover for attacks.
The drills were covered for attacks.
The former head of star wars missile
defense under presidents Ford and Carter
has gone public to say that the official
version of the nine 11 conspiracy,
it's a conspiracy theory and his main
suspect for the architect of the attacks
is Vice President Dick
Cheney. Whoa. That's fucking
shit. You get murdered over.
Wow.
People get murdered for way less because
it is funny though that people don't
want to hear that.
It is funny that Pete,
this is something the anger people read
about his background. Is He legit? Oh yes.
It's a legit guy. Yeah, he's 100%
legit. He was the head of Star Wars.
Star Wars is a very interesting program,
and I think we've talked about
this on the podcast before,
but star wars scientists
have been murdered like a,
a great number of them.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean here, here we go,
conspiracy guys to deny the nine 11 shit.
The head of Star Wars is
saying it was all bullshit.
That kid a fucking star wars. God Damn,
and you're still going to deny it.
Well, there's so much evidence, right?
But in all fairness,
he's a scientist and he could
be some crazy left winger.
And just because he's a genius
scientist doesn't mean he's not.
Yeah, but where people always
talk about credibility, if they,
if they would say if some, if they, if
there was some guy on the street and said,
I saw bombs. I heard bombs go off. They
call. He's just some dude on the street.
Now we've got former head of star wars
that he could be crazy. You can't just,
at some point you got to go, God
dammit. At some point you got to go.
Of course it's fishy.
Of course there's people banning together.
22 star wars researchers,
all committed suicide,
22 all committed to this. Yeah, of
course. Nice. Amazing. Well there's, I'll,
I'll deal with the, you
know, the, the thing was,
the idea was the conspiracy theory was
that the star wars program was bullshit
and it was never worked.
And they never had some real missile
defense shield that they get shoot and
space knock fucking missiles
out of the sky or staples.
They never developed
that level of technology.
So they had sort of hide the fact
that it was a big giant money grab.
They tried to look into it,
Congress approved that whoever the fuck
approved did they look into it and then
it just started stealing money.
So all these scientists that were involved
in this, that knew it was horse shit.
They just knock them all off. That's the
kind of money that you're dealing with.
You're dealing with the kind of money
that can kill 22 researchers, allegedly,
allegedly. Yeah. Sounds
about right. Right. Crazy.
Totally believable. The, I'm the witnesses
of the Kennedy assassination. This is a,
a new, uh, video that, uh, what is
his nickname on youtube? Mr Brick?
Maker 37 is uh,
he's uh,
the Tangerine show or Tangerine
show rather on Twitter.
He made this video and in the video he
talked about it was a clip of us on the
podcast talking about the witnesses to
the Kennedy assassination and how many
witnesses died. Uh, because of their,
they were murdered car accidents,
electrocution suicide got hit by trains.
Like crazy amount of them died
in a documentary about this.
And then they sent the,
uh, they did their,
their calculation
was that the odds of all of these
people who had witnessed this one event
getting murdered or were
killed in accidents in such
a short period of time was
one in something trillion to one.
Yeah,
that shit over as one point.
Something over and over again.
All that shit.
People don't want to guys are paranoid.
I'm proud. It's, it's a sexy idea.
But Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
They've already proven you
could shoot that rifle.
There's that certain sort of delusional,
conservative sort of Patriot type radio
guide voice that they do where you're
talking nonsense. They've uh,
they've all filled out the dossier.
It's all completed. Sorry.
Sorry. Hippies. Sorry. Okay.
Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
Thank you. That's scary shit man.
But these are like in mindset and
they want to lock into an ideology.
We figure out how much evidence would
it take to take like the biggest,
uh, debunker dude take it. How
much evidence will it take?
Will it if they,
if like Dick Cheney came out
and admitted it when they,
they've got no Dick Cheney,
he lost his mind with that new heart.
A new arts are liars. Hearts. Yes,
exactly. People would believe that shit.
Of course it would. A lot
of people would. Well,
there's a lot of people that want
to believe that the governments,
their daddy government's gonna
take care of them, I think.
I think if everyone consciously tried
to make all their friends aware of the
truth, look into it. People are
constantly looking, doing I cabi Vasquez,
I was with him last week.
We were in El Paso doing a Gracie
nationals tournament and he just recently
started looking into conspiracy
theories and it's like changed his, uh,
he kept going on and on and
how it's changed his life
and his wages and you just
actually got to look into it, you
know? Well, people can spire. I mean,
if people don't believe that, this
is my question, that I always say,
do you believe in nine 11? Do you believe
nine 11 happened? Well, if you do,
that's a conspiracy isn't, it?
Isn't a conspiracy, didn't they?
These guys can spire to make that happen.
Do you believe that the
Japanese attacked World War II?
They attacked to a Pearl Harbor?
Well then you believe in conspiracy
theories because the Japanese conspired to
sneak attack with jets and bomb the fuck
out of people. That's real. Like they,
they really plan that out,
you know?
Do you believe that Hitler
burned the right stack to,
to get people to think that the, you
know, that the Nazis were under attack?
Do you believe that Nero burned Rome?
Do you believe in any of these crazy?
We then you believe in
conspiracies, man, they,
they're documented throughout history.
People have been conspiring it bullshit
and forever men, they've always done it.
They always will if they can
get away with it to pull it off.
A bunch of evil fucks work together.
They know each other real well.
They partied together, they kill hookers
together and they get together and go,
you know what? Why are we fucking
playing by the rules here?
Well let's just rob these pitches.
Let's rob these bitches.
And they lost touch knuckles and
they go after it and they, they,
they pay money to get
lobbyists to change laws to
make it easier for them to fucking
move money around and they just,
they keep that party rolling and they
leave so much evidence land around.
It doesn't matter. It doesn't pass
it matter. Well in this day and age,
I think it started a matter.
I think what's going on now with the
Internet is that young people coming up
with the,
a realization of how the system works.
A realization of just human life
in general. When I say the system,
a realization of countries and taking
other other countries' resources in the
hall,
it's the people that are coming up.
It's going to be way harder for the
children of the people that live today to
justify the way the world runs in the
future because all this information will
be out there.
Whereas when we were kids,
when I was growing up in
the 1970s there was no,
there was no information
about any of this.
We never had any idea how the fucking
world war and he had to go to a library.
If you wanted to get information and
you had to find the right book and who
knows what that book is even right.
You could even fact check it. You know?
It was difficult to find out
what the fuck was going on,
but now pretty much anybody with a phone
has instant access to almost any answer
to any question they have or
at least reasonable, you know,
to a reasonable extent. That's
going to change everything, man.
I think we're just seeing it right now.
We're the beginning of the wave.
I think the wave behind us is
the wave that can't be ignored.
There's going to be a group of
people that know everything.
They have all the information.
It's not like your regular person that
lived in the 1970s that went to school
for a certain thing and then
live in a certain neighborhood.
Now you're going to be influenced by all
the humans all over the planet all the
time and that's what's going
on right now with Twitter.
That's what's going on right
now with this fucking podcast.
That's what's going on
right now with Facebook.
That's what's going on right now with
anybody that starts their own podcasts and
anybody who starts their own message
board and anybody that starts their own
thing where they're reaching out and
communicating with people and other people
lock into it and next thing you know,
you got your own little
online party going on, man.
You got your own little online party
going on. That's never existed.
No one has ever had that sort of an
openness in the past before to open access
to information in the past before,
we've never been able to just
communicate with people like this.
So we're going to get to know each other
more in the next hundred years than we
have in the last million years.
We're going to get to know
how we handle the real,
raw fucking truth of everything.
Because in the wild,
there's going to be no more secrets.
You're not gonna be able to hide money.
You're not going to be able to hide
where resources are coming from.
You're not to be able to hide anything.
Everybody's going to know exactly
what's going on all the time,
and that's when we're going to have to
either get our shit together as a species
or start using these fucking bombs we've
been storing up. It's one or the other
when they see guys like Brian.
Yeah,
they see this as part of the problem.
When we were talking about, I dunno,
I'm talking about a bad guys going
after you to protect freedom. Freedom.
Are you worried about terrorist attacks?
You ever think about it?
Anything can happen, Bro.
Shit, they already, of
course. Yeah. I mean, anything
could happen if they do it. Really?
Or did it go down as the
head of Star Wars says,
and there's a fucking Dick Cheney
who knows exactly how it went down.
Add that to the checklist. I thought
I shut it off. I swear to God.
Ladies and gentlemen, we've been doing
so many shows to the other studio.
I'm more concerned about bad
Sushi than I am about terrorism.
I had bad Sushi and I ruined my day,
my fucking weak.
But I think about that more than
I think about like, oh no, my,
this plane's going to go
down, you know, or, um,
I don't think people worry about it.
It's going to happen to them personally,
the odds, but another terrorist attack
for sure. It's going to keep happening.
Unless Bryce listeners to just shelter
world. I'm worried about boots. Sue.
She's so silly and everybody gets food
poisoning ever again. That ain't shit.
I'm scared. People in Iraq eat
food poisoning for breakfast. Okay.
That's what I have for
breakfast every day. Do, man,
you're lucky. You're lucky. You live here
in America. You've got to roll the dice.
He not living in fucking taboo.
You know, living in Pakistan,
launching missiles from
the sky with drones.
See Florida says that they're going to
have the most drones out of any, every,
any state because was just crazy.
Is it that that's a reality.
It's a weird word. Was going to do. Again,
what are they going to keep
track out things, photograph.
Things are going to be in the,
in the sky in case we ever need them.
Like say if there's some sort of a high
speed pursuit that drones will be able
to follow you from the sky and for
sure drones are going to be above you.
If you plan on doing any speeding,
go kiss that shake of it.
There's no more speeding because there's
going to be drones that are going to
monitor your speed and then they get an
alert the police to where you are and
the police are going to cut you off.
I can't wait till people start hacking
these. The good, you know that's,
it's going to happen. Well, that's
what happened. And I ran, you know,
pack it in Texas. Yeah. They can hack
a man. It's, it's a real problem.
It's going to be a real,
it's a radio frequency man.
Some super genius due to smarter than
you who wouldn't be working for the
government is going to figure out
a way to fuck with that shit. Yeah.
There's Jones be acting a fool any like
just a day after they released those
things. Yeah. I wonder
how crackable they are,
but I've got to assume
that anything that's uh,
using radio frequency is you
gotta be able to crack that.
They're going to figure out how the would,
the frequency one is going to fall on
a child and that it's just going to be,
well it already has in Pakistan,
if, you know, if you're in a,
if you're in Pakistan,
you're walking with your kid is no
guarantee that you're not going to get hit
with a missile. You know,
that's, that's real. You know,
they're fucking firing missiles from
the sky and we're not even like really
officially over there,
cause we're not over.
There are robots were over there shooting
fire from the sky like fucking hell
man. It's amazing where we are.
Terminators happening for them.
When you were a kid,
you remember watching terminator,
you imagine watching that was it.
Which one was one where they uh,
the things were flying in the
air and they were shooting down.
Was that the first terminator two
was it terminates Judgment Day?
Is that what it was?
Okay.
It's going on right now.
Blade runner. Runner. We're
right in it. There's drones. It's fucking
drunk. Slide around. What the fuck?
That was pretty fucking quick.
They just appeared. Yeah.
They said they're going to be 30,000
of them in the country within 10 years,
but we need anonymous
on that fucking route.
He's going to be a mass. Well they
got rid of those traffic cameras.
Have you noticed that those traffic
cameras to take pictures of you going
through the yellow light or red box to
have him? They got rid of them. Yeah.
They got rid of them cause I said,
I think they're unconstitutional.
I think there's something about
them that's a, that's illegal.
I think it's because it's a private
company that put them up and the private
companies somehow or another
was profiting off of these, uh,
people getting photographed going
through red lights and someone,
someone questioned it. I'm doing a
terrible job of butchering the, uh,
the argument or the story, but rather,
but, uh, I think that's what happened.
Do you have any problem with
Johan and on me? No, man.
That was just a very
disjointed podcast today.
We really didn't get it together ever
for ever more than 10 minutes at a time.
Next time we got to stop at like two hits.
I think two weeks is good on one.
There's two joints. We did smoke too
much. We went, we went to crazy D's.
I apologize.
Yeah.
Well that's why I wasn't
even upset at Brian for,
for logging into the beginning part.
You were so stolen.
You didn't know what the
fuck you're doing. I don't
even know what was going on.
You silly bitch. You didn't know what
the fuck was going on. Yeah. There's a,
there's a certain level where you really
shouldn't be talking into a microphone
in front of thousands of people when you
get high guy was that was that level.
Like right now we're perfect right
now we can cook with gas down.
This a fucking portal thing
is so confusing to me.
All this space stuff is so confusing
to me because I keep wanting to be the
skeptic. I keep wanting to
be the guy and he's like,
nothing's going to happen now. They're
going to happen. I wasn't going to happen.
It's just life's going to be the same.
They'll discover a new planet.
You can't see it. Who gives a fuck?
Yeah. The thing's going to happen.
Let's get video of that.
Yeah, and the creatures on it.
That's how discovery channel's about
other planets. I mean, how fucking cool.
We're so, you know, we have like, we're
so impatient when it comes to, you know,
discoveries and things,
we want it all to happen like all at once.
Like when we look back in time,
it like what Galileo,
it figured out or
Copernicus had figured out.
I mean it's all stuff that
pretty much everybody knows now,
but back then it was just mind blowing
revelations about the nature of the
universe.
Now if you look at what like we know now,
you know our little baby ass is known
now and what they're going to know.
If we could just keep it together for a
hundred years just to keep it together
for a hundred years. Yeah, there's
going to be some crazy shit going on.
Thinking about a hundred wasn't 19,
12.
How much cocked did it suck in 1912.
It was terrible.
The cars were dog shit. If they
even existed, they were dog shit.
You're riding around on dirt roads.
Everybody stays.
Thought it was cool that we get that
cars for the first time. They're like,
Holy Shit, this is the most
amazing part of life here.
If we're not the edge of the
edge of technology, we have,
cars are going to think back
about us in 2000 years. Like, oh,
they didn't have hologram vaginas. I
think it's going to be, uh, you know,
we were always like looking for alien
life and we're always saying like,
we can't search alien life.
I don't think we're ready yet.
And I think because we're not ready yet
because we're not really quite smart
enough to tune in to whatever the fuck
their frequency they're on, you know,
wherever they are because of that.
That's why there's no evidence,
even though it makes sense.
I think we're going to come to a point
at a certain time where if our technology
expands and continues to expand,
it's going to get to a point where there's
no spot in the universe that we can't
traverse. I mean, ultimately, if
people live for a million years,
that's got to happen. I mean, what
we can do today is impossible. Well,
we can do in a thousand years from now
is going to be equally impossible to us
today. You know, everything
that's so normal,
like Wifi and cellular videos and texting
people pictures of your butt hole.
You know that notice I looked
right at Brian, when did that,
I mean we were thinking about what a
thousand years from now, what you're,
you're going to have things that you can't
even wrap your head around today. It,
it most likely will involve
the manipulation of space
and time. We're going to,
we're going to probably in a hundred
years from now have some ability to verse
long distances. That seems
possible. If we can get it,
if we can just get over like a few
technological humps. Oh, and again,
this is a hundred years from now.
What do you really think it's
possible know about the God particle.
They just kind of discovered her.
Sounds very confusing. Um, it's,
they,
there are 99.99% sure that they have
recreated this particle based on its mass.
And uh, they've, they've, they've
discovered some incredible shit, man.
I mean it's the whole idea
behind it is really mind blowing.
But what's going on is there,
they're tapping into the,
the conditions and recreating
the conditions that are
like a millisecond after
the big bang and they're finding these
parts of the universe that they had
theorized about. And one of them
is this Higgs Boson particle.
That's God particle.
It's fucking,
it's too hard for me to wrap my puny
brain around it, but when I do, it's, uh,
it's pretty staggering stuff.
If you stop and consider where we were
in 1912 and where we are today and where
we're going to be 2012 with
this discovery of the Higgs,
Boston Boson,
whatever the fuck,
how do what we say and whatever the fuck
they're going to figure out within the
next hundred years. I mean,
it's, what does that mean to
the, to the average person?
I don't know that we discovered the
God particle. I don't know nothing yet.
Nothing yet. But it could
mean everything. It could,
it's the God particle which stands dark
matter or dark matter. Here, let's,
uh, let's get a scientific
piece really quick. Okay.
We'll get a scientific explanation of it.
It's that c
two o coconut water. Sun,
Sun. Yeah. Note that, uh,
we are in my place today.
The reason being is because Brian
almost got cooked with electricity.
That's also why we don't
have our Alienware laptops,
but we are still supporting,
uh, Alienware and you know,
Josh Barnett was very happy that we did
that because they support fighters and
that's why we chose to do it.
It's a big giant ass computers if
you're a gamer than the shit man.
If have the game or if
you're like a hardcore Gamer,
they like the best computers doing
the three d one three d games portal.
I've been playing in three days
because the laptop is insane.
We got these mother fuckers got an 18,
he got an 18 inch, which is insane. It's,
it's pretty much like an
imax that you can fold it up.
I got a 17 inch and it's
pretty cool, man. The,
the keyboards are all
light up different colors.
It's huge resolution and it's
really smooth for playing gaming.
I'm doing pretty much using
it just for gaming now. Yeah.
That's the only reason to use it.
They're their monster computers.
If you're a hardcore game and
there's people like, you know,
oh he only wears like super
expensive and they are not that bad.
It's not cheap man. If you want a,
if you want a built up computer,
you know,
it can be expensive,
but that's just but not compared to
Mac price as Max til pretty expensive.
I realized cause I went to
alienware's but it's Chi quality shit.
I mean that's why if you want,
if you build it together yourself,
you could probably build it for cheaper.
But a, I'm not building anything myself,
man. I'm a grown man. Cooling. Yeah,
it doesn't have the that well those
laptops are special. Those are,
those are fucking cool items
to have around. But uh,
but the reason why we're not supported,
we're not sponsored by Alienware.
We're supporting a MMA. We're actually
sponsored by a company called punched.
What does it punch? Drunk love sacrifice
inside. I didn't punch entertainment.
So that's where it's coming down from.
So that they hooked us up with a
deal on the Alienware computers.
And linker said,
we try to support people that support MMA.
And we try to support good companies,
which is why I always talk about Cto,
which is a fucking awesome.
This coconut juice from Thailand and I
got a new case that they just sent me
that has pulp in it. I haven't fucked
with it yet. I just got it today.
Do me a favor. I'm going to do this
live. Do you have any CTO left and night?
That one right there?
Yes.
I want you to take a sip of that and
I want you to take a sip of this.
I'm not drinking it after you dry. I'll
wipe it off. I'll wipe it up. Good enough.
Start, stop. Don't want to do
it. Not Happening. All right.
You want to be a woman too much? No,
no. There's cam feels weird to me. Oh,
you got a bad can. I didn't
think so. Oh, go get another one.
See if it tastes different. I don't
know. I've never had a bad cam from them.
Is that something that happened? It was
just you. This is your, your reaction.
It's warm to you like this.
Better than that.
A non pasteurized. Oh,
it's warm. You know what?
Because one of them was loose,
which had been in my refrigerator for
all like weeks and the other one just got
it in the refrigerator right before the
podcast started that you just pull it
out of that big package I opened that can
see that case is not, that's not cold
yet. This stuff is, it's way better coal.
Better quote. Right? Yeah. Big Difference.
It tastes like it's completely
different than, yeah. Yeah.
Apparently they say that
it's from Thailand. Thailand.
Coconuts are the most delicious and sweet
when it comes to their coconut water.
But, uh, if you can get fresh coconut
juice like a if few near a whole foods,
you should try. It's super expensive,
but God damn is it good. It's delicious.
Fresh coconut juice where it hasn't been
pasteurized or homogenized just right
out of the coconut, but it doesn't
last very long. But man, if you get it,
there's a company called it a press
juicery that I use. They're great, man.
That's a good press.
Coconut juice is so delicious.
Uh, we're turning to you for conversation.
We're going to Vegas this weekend.
Last weekend. We never even broke
down. Silva versus Sonnen. Hmm.
I talk a little bit about it,
but we didn't get to,
do you think Anderson Silva was going
to be a completely different fighter?
This fight? Just don't fucking know. It
could be. Yeah. You wonder like you man,
he was, it was much easier to take down
than I expected in the first fight.
And he does, you know, that's it.
That is like a guy who was injured.
Like he didn't want to try to
stop the takedown. Who knows?
Maybe he's impossible to take down
at this point. Not going to happen.
I don't know about that. Maybe it's,
the whole thing is interesting.
When a guy fights injured,
you just don't know.
And Anderson's not a guy has ever said he,
he fought different than
he ever fought before.
And he's not a type of guy
that makes excuses in the past,
like a lot of people don't know that he
had double knee surgery just five weeks
before he beat Travis. Luder. That's
the heat, you know, that's what, uh,
his manager told me. He told me, I
mean, that's a crazy thing. What he did,
he fought Travis Luder like right when
you're supposed to like not even be back
to training again. Yeah.
You know, five weeks in.
So a guy who was willing to do that
and not tell anybody he did, you know,
beat Travis Luder a lot easier and more
convincingly than he'd be Chael Sonnen
though. So who knows? Who knows
how much it really bothered him.
But he won the bottom line is he figured
out a way to win and that's why it gets
interesting because if he's healthy
now and he doesn't have any injuries,
will he be able to stop
the shot now? Oh, you know,
will it be an easier fight for him
or will it be the same fucking thing?
Maybe sun and takes them down. Um,
maybe it's hard. Maybe it's easy,
but it takes him down and he and
his passing is getting better.
What if he passes and triangles is
atrophies? So that could happen.
He's been working with Vinny Maga.
Exactly. And Vinny says, Hey, and he,
he might be trying to blow up jail,
but he says that he thinks that shale
has the ability to finish Anderson and I
believe it,
any,
any wrestler at that caliber has
the ability to squeeze in act.
They just got to focus on it just
a little bit. You focus on it.
If he just focused on RM triangles and
we'll make it chokes and a good team just
keep polishing this shit every day.
Just keep drilling it slowly becoming
dangerous, which is those three.
And of course you got to
get really good at passing.
Passing the guard is just as
important as taking a guy down.
You've got to get really
good at passing camp.
Pass the guard man.
All you have is ground and pound and dude,
some nullify that pretty easily now.
So you got to,
and it seems like he's passing
and as fast past few fights,
his passing was looking good and uh,
you know,
he got her arm trying controlled
Bisping on the ground too,
which is really hard to do. Bisping
is very good defensively off his back.
You know,
jail wasn't able to submit him,
but he controlled him for
quite awhile on the ground.
But what he did with Brian Stan
was really impressive. Yeah,
he's smushed that guy. You look at it and
that's like some serious pressure. His,
his arm triangle is super legit. Brian.
Stan was defending the right way to,
but it was for, nope, you didn't matter.
He squeezes too hard when you
get a good one of those things,
when a guy really develops a good one,
when they really get a feel for it,
especially when they were a big wrestler,
like a chill son and guy already has
like a sick squeeze and it's sick.
Top game is sick balance and just
knows how to crush things down.
They lock onto one technique like
that. Man, they become so dangerous.
Even when year's Eve, when you're
defending, you still can get submitted.
Just crushes your fucking head.
You know?
If that guy gets a hold of your head
and arm, you're done so on, you're done.
It's amazing.
I'll dude's like Cody McKenzie.
They just lock onto one fucking
technique and get so laser sharp at it.
They pull it off on everybody,
even though dudes know they're trying
to pull it off. We got obsessed with it.
They put a lot of numbers in.
That can happen with any technique
that Cody Mackenzie's fucking guilty.
It's ridiculous. It's ridiculous.
I've never seen a guy,
what does he have like 11 wins by
gay t now? Something like that.
So kratom incredible.
Always chokes at the same arm.
Joey said that there was Marcel, he
always showed his right arm. It's amazing.
Yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm still sad that
Marcel never got back into MMA.
He had a one fight or he got cut and a,
he had a hard time using
the gloves at our time.
Strangling a guy with those gloves on.
I guess it makes a big goddamn difference.
And then the grease two
got to get used to that.
There's a big difference between gay and
Nogi and then there's a big difference
between rash guard and no rash
guard. Yeah, that's right.
It's not the same thing.
It's way more Slippy, Slippy
point man. Do you think that,
like when, when you see guys in Abu
Dhabi and things along those lines,
do you think that they
should be able to wear pants?
Do you think they should be a little
aware? Well, and I'm with obviously cow.
You can't wear pants. You wear the
pants. You could wear anything you want.
You could wear a g if you
want it. Really? Yeah.
You can wear anything and I would not be.
And can your opponent grab that key? Um,
you know what,
there's,
there's some tournaments out there that
have ridiculous rules that they just
don't, it's just the most
ignorant shit out there.
It's amazing that it still exists.
Like some tournaments,
they allow you to work g pants
and I know g tournament, but uh,
your opponent can grab them and
in control, but you can't grab it.
And control shorts. I said,
yeah, let them control the pants.
But why can't I grab his shorts?
He's grabbing my pants just because his,
his pants are shorter.
It makes zero sense.
If you're going to allow someone to grab
pants, you should be able to grab shorts
or don't allow it at all. Don't allow
grabbing at anything. Just seems weird.
If you have pants on and you have a g on,
you're allowed to grab it,
but if you just both are wearing shorts,
you're not allowed to grab it.
It's ridiculous. It gets tricky. Yeah,
it's stupid shit like you think
they should have to do that?
Everybody should have to
fight just skin on skin.
Just valley to those shorts and that's it.
No,
I think you should be able
to wear anything you want.
I like the way the Japanese ran it.
If you want to come in with a a kito gay,
let them come up with an a keno game.
What happens is,
is that the boxing people
that made all these rules,
they didn't understand what was exactly
what was going on, what you did.
So they thought we're going to,
we're not going to give
anybody an unfair advantage.
So we're going to take away
the key because people,
they saw hoists choking out Ken shamrock
with this color or with his sleeve.
But really in Japan you
can want anything you want.
And if the pants were that dangerous,
all the Brazilians would be wearing pants.
How come? No, no. Brazilians are
wearing pants except for hoists.
The pants aren't dangerous.
What they do is try to even out the
playing field because people are wearing
fucking, uh, uh, Vaseline.
People or Vaseline binders are
always squeezing themselves up.
Strikers are you kidding?
They don't want to go out
there and get strangled at all.
Putting on Greece the night before.
It's not all a lot though.
Not all, but a lot. How are they doing it?
What do you think is the most common
way they do it? If people like, uh,
this is what I've heard is it'll take
like cocoa butter and like sleep with it
and then wash it off the next morning.
So your,
your skin appears to be dry and
then when you start sweating,
it comes out of your pores. That's, you
know, even finding a leg lock wizard,
you're going to shave your fucking
legs in, grease up. You know? And,
and not only that, not only that,
another thing that came from boxing,
that's what's up with all the
Vaseline all over people's faces.
You don't think that gets
all over their bodies.
A lot of times people get accused of
greasing and Henderson is in fights,
wiped it off his face and under his
chest. Well, whether you do that or not,
when you're fighting and you're grappling,
dude's touching your face,
touching your chin and he's touching
your arm. It's, these guys are, are,
or have Vaseline all over their body
by the end of the fight. So that's a,
an unfair advantage to a striker. You
know, it's harder to get submissions.
We should be pushing to get
more submissions. You know,
in professional football
they push for more authentic.
They change rules and adjust shit for
more often. Same thing in basketball.
What you're saying is that if they
wore just allowed to wear rash guards,
that would basically even up all the
problems that we have with grease.
If you want to.
You don't have to if you want to.
Some people don't want to wear shit cause
remember and in Japan you could wear
anything you want and what the Jujitsu
guys chose to wear his little tiny shorts.
They just had a lot of ways for
us. We went to pants. Yes, yes.
No pants top with pants on.
But then he ended up fighting MMA was
shortens no ports for 25 when he fought
Matt Hughes. That was
one. So that was again,
they didn't allow him to wear
anything else. Yeah, totally.
And the fact that pants are like karate
pants or a geek pans are not allowed to
wear like tights, like the
way a Aoki wears tights. It's,
it's counterproductive for the sport,
you know,
it just let them go would be a good
way to counteract the idea. You know,
everybody's greasy, greasy people
are greasy and if they're not,
they got Vaseline all over their face.
It's going to get all over their body
and it makes it hard to all that Vaseline
all over your face makes it harder to
pull off submissions late in the fight.
You mixed that Vaseline with sweat and
blood we should be like, it would be like,
uh,
like banning tights would be like banning
a wide receivers wearing gloves in
like rainy days or snowy days.
They let them wear gloves so they
could catch the ball. More authentic,
more drop balls means shitty play.
People get bored,
they want more high scoring. But that's
not a person, the balls on a person.
The problem is,
the idea is that someone should be able
to have the best defense possible with
two men with bare skin. Yeah. I've also,
one guy's wearing some sticky close
and a lot of it, but it's okay.
And the amateurs in California, they let
him wear rash guard. It's no problem.
Yeah. In the amateurs you were
rash guards, just no problem.
What about after that you
would change the game? Female,
female MMA fighters where rash guards.
How was that? Okay, that's unfortunate.
Yeah, totally. But like how has
that, I mean, how's that? Okay.
They have an unfair advantage.
You should be allowed.
You should be allowed to wear rash guards.
I mean it works in female and then a,
it should, we should allow it in
the pros to what's the big deal?
It's just a rash guard.
It'd be nice.
People would come in with like tights
and they look like little super hero
characters.
It'd be cool.
Like Aoki was just his famous for
the different crazy pants. He waters.
It was for his fighting
some down for a tights.
The only problem that I would have with
the [inaudible] is that you can use the
gears and weapon.
You get to Zeke,
you'll choke the fuck out of somebody and
that doesn't feel yes, yes, but again,
in pride they allowed that,
but no, but the, there's,
there's way more cons to pros that were
in geese. As far as the Geek experts.
The expert said, you know what? Yeah,
I could choke you out with my sleep,
but dude can choke me out with my
own color so it's not even worth it.
You know what I mean? Amber, you
remember when Yoshida, Fort Hoists? Yep.
Yoshida fought hoists and he said he
was out and he wasn't out. He lied.
Totally made up. The fact that
he was out, he's like, he's,
he's not even barely choking them
voices, like foot was up and shit. I,
there was no way he
could've been out like his,
he was like holding his foot
up and now he's out. He's out.
And then like reverie stops and he's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I ain't out. They totally
bamboozle them. Yeah.
There's a lot of tomfoolery going
on in Japan and that was with a,
that was where the Ie, you
know, he was wrapping them
up in the gate. It goes away.
But again, it's, it's, it's, if it
was an advantage to where Aggie,
all the Brazilians coming
over and fighting and pride
that all be wearing gies
and g pants, you know what I
mean? It's not an advantage.
So amazing that hoist chose to
fight like that though. He was,
but then when you watch like Hickson's
fights with Zulu, he never wore a,
he worried a little tight
shorts. Yeah. Interesting. In the
long run, the is a disadvantage.
That's what the Brazilians
are saying by not wearing it.
They're making that statement.
Yeah. That's kind of crazy.
When you stop and think about it, there's
this ancient outfit that people were,
you know, they'd been wearing for how
long? Thousand years. Who knows how many,
how many years of martial artists from
wearing baggy, you know, or taekwondo,
they call the Doh Buck, you know, and
uh, I dunno, what is it called? Kim Mono.
Is that what the Portuguese
like to call it? The Brazilians?
I think that's a Japanese word. Yes. But
they use the word Kimona was falling,
right? Yeah. Japanese definitely
called Kimono. But that's what, uh,
that's what the Brazilian Jujitsu guys
referred to it, right? Yeah. Yeah.
We didn't accept Kimono.
We took g and that weird when it got
over here became a gay cause it went from
being Komono to the Brazilian Japanese
Kimono and Brazilian Komono g in the
Brazilians didn't call it G. I don't know.
I think Americans don't Americans, uh,
very rarely called Kimonos.
And when they do, you know,
there are serious Jujitsu Dork.
You know,
somebody asks you what Brand Kimono
do you were you serious Jujitsu Dork?
Some dude's just get so caught up
in Jujitsu mad. It's just like,
it's so much fun when you
first start tapping guys.
It becomes so much fun that some guys
just completely lose their shit and just,
just dive into it. Yeah. I
was just too fucking free.
I was thinking about getting out.
One of those Americans are so into it.
I love Brazil.
Went to Brazil in 2010 in 2003.
I fucking love anything Brazilian.
Anytime a Brazilian was fighting and MMA,
he could be fighting a Mexican.
I don't give a shit. I'm gone for the
Brazilian. I'm, oh, I was so hardcore.
I would've got a tattoo of a Brazilian
flag on my bag with that. Oh,
Denny progressive thing on it. I would
consider that shit. That is a dose.
Hardcore Dope logo. The
presenter. Oh dammit.
You Progresso.
Uh,
like maybe a then my guess is
a oath promise to progress.
I don't know.
Some fun country man pursued it.
They're the only country that
shuts down for a month to party.
It's beautiful man. There are
people down. They're really fun.
I really enjoyed doing
the UFC is down there.
The audiences are like nothing you've
ever seen in your life. In between fights.
They were doing the wave
and screaming and cheering.
I mean like the level of passion that
the Brazilian fans have. It's not,
no one's close. No one is close. Not
Americans. And we've been everywhere.
We've been fucking, no
one's, no one's closed.
Smash everybody with loyalty,
sell it.
Celebration, you know, singing
and Jujitsu tournaments.
I went to Brazil in 2000
for the worlds and it was,
it wasn't out of like a giant place.
It was kind of like at an old beat up
kind of arena. Like a mini beat up arena.
It was like a,
it wasn't that great.
And those motherfuckers had drums
and shit. They had all these chats.
It was like a high school
gym and they were going nuts.
They would have crushed your leaders.
They would have fucked him off.
Do you remember?
Um,
when we were in Abu Dhabi and they
started singing in the middle,
like jock array was fighting
and someone started the deal.
It sounded like they got songs, man. Yeah.
Singing and pounding on the tables or
the, uh, the chairs like drums. I mean,
it's amazing, man. They, they got into
it to the point where it was like,
it was like you were like, it was like,
uh, you're, you're privileged to be there.
Like you didn't know that
there was a place like this.
He didn't know that this was,
that this was something that was
going on out there in the world.
He wants these bad ass Jujitsu guys
fight and then these Brazilian guys are
singing and dancing in the fucking crowds.
And do you think it's a
coincidence that Brazil,
maybe the only country or the only country
part of the UN? I don't know exactly,
but Brazil is super rare in the,
they go against you and drug policies
and make Iowasca Legal Eagle there.
You think that has, I mean, I hear
that in Brazil and I could be wrong,
but I saw this in documentary.
It could be bullshit, but they,
that a lot of people give,
there's like an io, there's an,
I lost a Christian religion that's kind
of like a mesh of boat and they give I
WASC it a babies,
they give Iowasca when you're 14 to
prevent alcoholism somehow if you have,
um,
I WASC in your system before alcohol or
maybe even after some in some way does
something to your brain or
somehow spiritually, I dunno,
but it keeps you from being an alcoholic,
a waste case. And Brazil is like,
fuck it.
I WASC is legal bitch.
And who parties harder than Brazil
who celebrates more than Brazil?
Those guys are fucking insane.
I'm sure it has to have some impact.
But marijuana is illegal. They're really,
uh, really illegal. It's not good at all.
You gotta be, you know, gotta
be what it is. It is illegal.
But a lot of Brazilian jujitsu players,
they smoked weed.
Very popular in Jujitsu, but it's,
sorry, you got to have to deal with some,
you know,
people that are selling illegal drugs
and the weirdest shit down there too.
So I think South America just all
together shit weed. It's unfortunate.
It's ridiculous. And it's uh, it's
uh, hopefully one day. I mean,
can you imagine if Brazil had
medical marijuana? Oh my God.
If Brazil had legalized weed on top of
the way they rocket right now on top of
the greatest crowds of all time
on top of the most insane beaches.
You look out and see islands and shit.
Dudes are selling coconuts.
If they had weed for free
too, I mean, legal weed. Yeah,
it would be the most
ridiculous country of all time.
It's weird how cultures
just grow up and it's,
a lot of it is depending on
how bad where you live sucks.
You couldn't have a lifestyle like Brazil.
If you lived in Iceland like bitch,
you got to go out and kill a whale.
Okay.
It's a fucking were when a freeze
to death. Okay, we need some food.
We need to batten down the hatches.
We need to not in Brazil,
you don't have to batten down the hatches.
It's awesome out even in the winter,
it's awesome. So what do they do? They
they fucking party. That's totally cool.
It's totally
Brazilian and totally cool and not to
be like honest, like a strict schedule.
They love to say, hey, you
know when you're in Brazil,
he and Machado told him in this man,
I went to Brazil the first time.
We kept telling him like, we got
to do this. We're going to do that.
Goes relax in Brazil there is no time.
There's no time in Brazil and like,
Whoa,
these guys do whatever the fuck they
want to do whenever they want to do it.
It's all about having fun. There's a
dude that I met down there that was a,
I think he's a Machado black.
I forget his name, I apologize.
But he was telling me that
he moved back there and uh,
the late nineties he
moved in Brazil and uh,
just started living there and
he just loved it. And he said,
the one thing that you got to get used
to though is like when you need something
fixed,
like good luck.
You need to do the show but your house
at a certain time, well he might show up,
you know, but you know, shit happens.
I remember in the early nineties one
Jujitsu blew up because of hoists. Gracie,
because of the UFC,
a lot of Brazilians started fucking
making the move and opening up shop and
taking territory's and
so went to New York.
How went to San Francisco and
Machado's went to southern California.
Horry on southern California.
Everyone's just like,
it's like the gold rush
for Brazilian Jujitsu.
You think about how many high
level Jujitsu schools are
in California? Hell yeah,
they're all coming to California nuts.
They're all coming in and Miami,
they want the nice weather. They want
the nice weather, they want the surfing,
but they're still go to Toronto.
Brazilians are locators,
man. Don't fucking real.
Okay. Just, yeah, there's
some, there's some spots that
is wide open, but you know,
you really want to open shop in Wisconsin
or something and then you want to go
to hang for a while.
Cause like even Salo and Shonda,
they went to Ohio for a while.
They went,
but there's only so much a Brazilian
kid could do in Hawaii or in Ohio.
So they said fuck it. They
came to San Diego. Well, I'm
like, uh, what's his name?
Um, a no pile. Gabriel Gonzaga.
He's in western Massachusetts. Man,
it's cold as fuck out there.
Right. Big Difference.
Cause Marcella went to New York and
then he went to Florida and they said,
fuck it. He didn't like the weather in
Florida. He went back. He loves New York.
Well, New York is, if you're a thinking
person, and Marcel was a thinking person,
New York is much more stimulating,
more stimulating people.
Florida is nice and everything like that.
But God damn though,
I mean intelligence level in Florida
Henzel some fucking New York.
Kenzo fucking owns New York
did he is the Godfather.
He's like John Gotti of Jujitsu that our,
he is that shit. Fuck yeah. And he's got,
he's got a ridiculous number of students.
Yeah.
And he's making some serious
bank and that guy and he's,
he's one of the nicest guys on the planet,
you know what I mean? He's fucking,
he's on Twitter all the time. Just
spreading positivity. You know,
Marcello on Twitter, he's on Twitter.
Not as much as Hanzo. Those on Twitter.
Fucking I'm like, isn't it like five
in the morning in New York right now?
And he's still like, just
Twitter, all just positive
shit. Pencil is just positive.
Positive
is he's aware. Where are they? How
far away are they from each other?
Handle school and Marcel school
and they're really close.
They're both in Manhattan.
Really close.
But Marcel also has a very
successful school too, but hands are,
I think Hanzo has been around forever.
Yeah. Marcel was much more recent.
But Marcello has that Josh Waitzkin
dude, that chest wizard. That was, yup.
I met him last time, I was
in New York. Really cool guy.
I exchanged some emails with them.
Brown Marcello's guys are fucking so cool.
The guy that they based the movie
searching for Bobby Fischer. Yup. Yup.
He was a chess genius.
Spent all his life doing that.
And then he got into martial arts and
initially got into Kung Fu and then uh,
I think he was doing push hands,
like those push hands competitions.
And then he got into Jujitsu and fell in
love with it and started breaking moves
down sort of the same way in a disciplined
approach to the way that he learned
to play chess.
You know,
cause they learn to like think of moves
and chains and progressions and so he
broke it down as a discipline,
you know, and made that Mj and uh,
mg inaction website and uh,
he's got all the different techniques
labeler and you have that shame shit going
on to add a at 10th planet Jiu
Jitsu [inaudible] Dot com right.
You can go there and you have it set up
where you have all the different moves
and techniques and someone doesn't
even have to like train here.
They can learn your shit online and
then bring it to a local Jujitsu gym and
practices. I release episodes of the
show called mastering the system.
I release one every few weeks and has
every technique that I teach at my school.
I put it up online for four 99 so yeah,
it's an amazing resource for
someone who lives somewhere.
Like say if you're stuck
somewhere and they,
they don't have any high level Jujitsu,
you can get together with your friends
and you could start a club, you know,
you can, you could, you know,
get a certain amount of people and
maybe they have mats at the y Ymca.
When I was a kid,
the why I'm say had mats like you could,
you could set some adds up
and you could start a club.
There's so many guys out there,
so many ruins.
They're getting two or three of their
friends putting mats in the garage. Again,
Marcello, you can study, you know, the
Mendez Brother Study Edrick of out,
you can get mastering the system, put it
all together and have some fucking fun.
And then they'll take trips.
Sometimes.
Like a lot of these guys
will come in and you know,
they'll train in Manhattan for a week,
you know,
like that's what George Saint Pierre did
when he was young when Hanzo and train
there, or they'll go to John jocks
or they'll go to your gym. You know,
we're in Burbank now,
folks who view,
if you were looking for the legends
went under due to unforeseeable
circumstances. So, uh, if you want
to learn some 10th planet Jiu Jitsu,
you have to go to our 10th planet, Burbank
location shoots on Burbank Boulevard.
What does the executor on 41
30 West Burbank Boulevard,
and it's a blue dragon
martial arts academy.
If you see the Blue Dragon martial
arts academies, so awesome tent. Yeah,
the big 10th planet logo right there.
But if you're driving in the street,
there's a white sign that like sticks out.
So if you find that that's what
you can learn from hedge it Bra,
learn to get the shogun. We're going
to have a good time this weekend, man.
It's kind of a fun, crazy
ass. It's going to be wild.
Fuck yeah man. Party time.
All right. You dirty bitches.
This has been a long and
disjointed podcast and we
apologize for it. And Brian,
you really got to get your shit together
because you can't do any of the things
that you, can I make a request. Can
I make a request, Joe? Yeah, sure.
I just dropped a new song and a,
I want to play it for you right now.
Is it too late? I think we have
like four minutes to it and yeah,
we only have three hours on a recording.
Okay. You can play it afterwards.
We'll stop and come back out
afterwards. Okay. We'll do that.
So we'll stop and come back and it
will be a supplemental to the podcast.
Ladies and gentleman, the Eddie Bravo
Song. Alright, you freaks next week.
We got a lot of shit going
on. We got Tommy Chong coming
up. We got Kevin Pereira.
Adam coke cash from Adam and versus
the man and honey honey. And uh,
we, we don't know if we might have to
move some people around. That's a lot.
Might have to do honey honey
a little earlier in the day.
And then next week we got Aubrey
who's returning from Peru and another
psychedelic adventury.
Then we got bobo from finding big foot.
I am very excited about that
one wins that Vietnam beyond.
Oh, she's uh, she's emailing
me. We're going back and forth.
We're going to figure it out.
You're a Kat von d responded
to me on Twitter today.
Can I gushed like a little
child it this weekend?
If you're going to see that UFC,
I'm going to be also doing a show.
Doug loves movie taping at power
station on Sunday and Doug loves movies.
For those who don't know
is the podcast of, uh, the,
I heard grumpy. Doug Benson,
Benson, Darien grumpy,
got an after party Saturday night at the
cat house at the Luxor worth the 10th
planet after Party after the UFC cat
house lugs or everybody's invited.
What is the cat house?
It's a small lounge.
I wanted a place where we could
get everybody in, you know?
And if we wouldn't have to haze or
something like excess, like those clubs,
you only get 10 guys in,
it gets crazy. I wanted to,
I put together a party where I made
sure that all my 10th planet people,
cause there's gonna be a bunch
of them there this weekend.
They get all get into one spot
without any trouble. And you know,
they've got a bar there, they got
music. It's just for 10 plan of family.
Any anybody that down, you
know, you don't have to be,
you don't have to go
to a 10 plan at school,
but it's after the UFC Saturday cat
house at the lug sore. Look for me.
Boom bitches. Um, that's about it. Oh,
if you're a fear factor fan,
the fear factor episode where we wash
shouldn't tell you what actually happens.
But uh,
there's a one two hour episode that we
filmed besides the donkey semen one that
won the tank in the show.
There's one other episode that we film
that's going to air over the next two
Mondays.
So I don't think they're advertising it.
They're just sticking it in a hole
and it's called burning it off.
So if you're interested and
you want to check it out,
you'll probably never see it. A goal and
you forget about that episode. Uh, no, no.
I remembered, you know, I'm so happy
that this thing turned out the way it did.
You know this,
it's very rare when someone,
their show gets canceled and they're
really had big canceled. I fucked up, man.
I would've been a lot.
Shut the fuck up the sub,
trying to make it God Dang confession.
Listen folks is fucking podcast is over.
We'll be back.
We'll be back next week with tons of fun
and we'll be in San Diego for comicon.
Yes, it, we'll be in San Diego
next Friday. Go to the desk.
I don't teach the 13 don. Tom, Tom.
Oh really? Yeah. And it's like where,
what is the name of the town?
The American comedy Co and good American
Comedy co.com or [inaudible] dot TV and
click on the banner at the top. All
right, three weeks. We will see you soon.
Thank you. God dammit. Fleshlight
on a podcast. I'll call you back.
Thanks to the flashlight
for sponsoring our podcasts.
Go to Joe rogan.net click on the link
for the flashlight entering the code name
Brogan and save yourself 15% off
the number one sex toy for man.
Thanks also to [inaudible]
dot com that's o, n n, I t.
Go check the Alpha brain son.
Go get yourself some new formula.
Has some awesome new ingredients that
are even better. Go check it out.
All the information is
available on [inaudible] dot
com and the kettle bells or
in the most reasonably Pi's kettlebells
you're going to find online,
including the most reasonably
priced battle ropes.
The battle ropes are the highest quality
available as how the kettlebells those
fucking kettlebells will.
We'll be there when the earth is not.
They are solid fucking iron
and they will find them.
Scientists will find them in your
fucking house. I'm doing a podcast,
Jesus Christ. I can't tell these people
enough and they yet they still call back.
I got to go. Ladies and gentlemen is
a lot of shit going down over here.
Thanks ana.com use the code name
Rogan and save yourself 10% off.
All are awesome brain supplements and
we will see you, uh, you guys soon.
Next week. Are we doing a nice, I'll
show next Wednesday. Next Wednesday.
ICEHOUSE powerful house. So
that's it for now and, uh,
we'll see you guys soon.